toujours hasina razafintsalama soldats
du 1er régiment de hussards
parachutistes de tarbes et morts dans
l'accomplissement de sa mission au
service de la france au sein de
l'opération barkan au mali je salue avec
un profond respect son courage et sa
détermination et j'adresse au nom de la
représentation nationale
mes plus sincères condoléances à sa
famille et à ses proches ainsi qu'à ses
frères d'armes
je vous invite à observer une minute de
silence
je vous remercie
l'ordre du jour appelle les questions au
gouvernement la parole est à madame
mathilde pas non monsieur le premier
ministre
quel est le point commun entre anthony
smith inspecteurs du travail
alex françois yacine patrick à mettre de
la ratp
farida infirmières les soignants de
l'hôpital psychiatrique du rouvray
les militants de bure et les gilet jaune
toutes et tous ont voulu remettre le
monde à l'endroit
anthony voulait sanctionner une
entreprise qui mettait en danger la
santé de ses salariés
les agents de la ratp exercer leur droit
de grève contre la réforme des retraites
qui pourrit nos vies farid a réclamé
plus de moyens pour l'hôpital public
les militants de bure lutte contre
l'enfouissement des déchets nucléaires
pour les générations futures
les gilet jaune pour la justice sociale
et la démocratie mais leur point commun
le plus évident tristesse de notre
démocratie et que vous avez voulu les
faire taire sans aucune honte le
président dit vouloir changer de méthode
sanctions disciplinaires révocation
répression policière et judiciaire
voici le triptyque réservé à celles et
ceux qui osent critiquer votre politique
et il n'a pas changé depuis trois ans
vous osez parler de dialogue et de
démocratie mais vous n'aimez la
démocratie qu'avec des citoyens passifs
et silencieux vous briser des vies tous
les jours
le sort des vies humaines n'est
définitivement pas votre priorité
je vous le dis solennellement un pouvoir
qui fait sans cesse recours à la force
pour se perpétuer et voué à un destin
funeste lever les sanctions contre
anthony smith contre alex à maître
françois yacine patrick et tous les
autres cesser d'envoyer les matraques
quand le peuple vous demande des comptes
cesser d'utiliser la force pour masquer
l'indigence de votre politique comme des
gilet jaune long très justement rappelé
emmanuel macron le président de la
république est comme nous tous dans cet
hémicycle
l'employé du peuple français qu'ils s'en
souviennent et respecte la souveraineté
populaire
alors monsieur le premier ministre à
quand une amnistie pour celles et ceux
qui défendent l'intérêt général et sont
injustement poursuivis pour leurs
actions généreuses
merci la parole est à monsieur gérald
darmanin ministre de l'intérieur
[Applaudissements]
mesdames et messieurs les députés
monsieur le président madame la députée
toute opinion en france peut s'exprimer
la liberté de manifester est garantie
par la constitution elle est d'ailleurs
encadré toute personne peut d'ailleurs
se présenter à des élections s'ils le
souhaitent contester même dans la rue
les résultats et même l'opinion est
dictée par une majorité
en quelle qu'elle soit mais madame la
députée l'état de droit veut bien dire
aussi ce qu'il veut dire
les forces de l'ordre sont légitimes
dans l'exercice de la force justement
parce qu'ils sont le produit d'un état
de droit
parce que justement dans des élections
libres disputées démocratique
nous établissons un certain nombre de
règles que nous faisons respecter et
parmi ces règles que nous faisons
respecter madame il ya à la fois bien
évidemment la liberté totale de
manifester je pense que les français ont
pu voir à la télévision dans leur rue
que cette liberté était grande dans
notre pays et c'est tant mieux mais il
ya aussi des forces de l'ordre madame
qui sont les premières victimes des
violences
aujourd'hui c'est des madame la députée
en 2019
ces onze mille policiers et gendarmes
qui ont été agressés en 2019
ces sept décès de policiers et de
gendarmes en service qui n'ont pas
retrouvé leurs familles qui n'ont pas
embrasser leurs enfants qu'ils sont
entrés dans des conditions matérielles
difficiles
alors madame la députée
nous sommes tous les deux d'accord pour
dire que la liberté de manifester grand
notre pays et la liberté est grande
bien sûr pour pouvoir s'exprimer on a
manifestement en désaccord
pour ma part je suis très fier de police
de la république mais aussi monsieur le
ministre
la parole est à madame agnès firmin le
bodo
merci merci monsieur le président
monsieur le premier ministre après une
consultation menée par le ccn eu un
rapport de l'opecst ce une mission
d'information conduite par xavier breton
et jean louis tourenne un avis du
conseil d'état le projet de loi
bioéthique a fait son entrée à
l'assemblée nationale en août 2019
depuis ce sont plus de 200 heures de
travaux qui ont été menés notamment par
la commission spéciale que j'ai eu
l'honneur de présider
science sans conscience n'est que ruine
de l'âme disait rabelais science
conscience éthique l'articulation est
difficile l'équilibré précaire
mais tout ceci bhl tout ceci
terriblement humain redoutablement
humains les lois bioéthiques dit à la
française ont cette fonction nous devons
être sage et cette sagesse nécessite de
savoir ce que la science peut et ce que
nous humains pouvons accepter
vaste ambition ces lois sont structurées
par trois grands principes la dignité la
solidarité et la liberté
vaste ambition disait que nous avons
collectivement aborder avec humilité et
force de travail et qui avait abouti en
première lecture à un texte
à mon sens équilibré juste et adaptée
aux besoins actuels des françaises et
des français je tiens d'ailleurs à
remercier l'ensemble de mes collègues
qui ont permis ce travail passionnant
souvent passionnées mais toujours dans
l'idée de respecter les idées des uns et
des autres nous avons eu de beaux débats
je retiendrai notamment nos échanges sur
la pma post mortem qui resteront comme
un moment important de mon expérience
parlementaire
ce texte a bel et bien un objet
multiples des inquiétudes lié aux
progrès en génétiques au développement
dans le domaine de l'intelligence
artificielle du chanteur aux
neurosciences mais aussi des
préoccupations regard des aspirations
sociétal avec l'accès à la pma pour les
couples de femmes et les femmes seules
il s'agit également d'accompagner la
solidarité dans le cadre du don
d'organes de tissus et de cellules le
possible ce que la science permet
n'est pas le probable ce que l'humain
peut accepter et encore moins le
réaliser ce que la loi autorise alors
monsieur le premier ministre ma question
est simple
alors où débute la deuxième lecture du
projet de loi bioéthique pouvez vous
nous donner votre opposition et celle du
gouvernement sur le texte aujourd'hui
soumis à nos travaux la parole est à
monsieur le premier ministre monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
députés
madame la députée firmin le bodo merci
beaucoup de me donner l'occasion de
m'exprimer pour la première fois sur ce
sujet majeur
[Applaudissements]
on se calme je voudrais si vous le
permettez après votre intervention
rendre hommage sur ce sujet à votre
assemblée et à la majorité parlementaire
pour la richesse et la qualité du texte
qu'elle a voté en première lecture en
octobre dernier
d'abord en raison d'abord à raison du
travail particulièrement dense et le
sujet le mérite de concertation qui a
été menée et qui dois je vous le
rappeler a fait suite à six mois de
travaux et des changes avec le conseil
national d'éthique
ensuite et surtout pour le caractère
très approfondie et très fécond des
discussions conduites dans les
commissions et dans cet hémicycle
surtout les banques sur le fonds
à l'initiative du gouvernement dirigé
par mon prédécesseur et dans le cadre
des engagements pris devant la nation
par le président de la république
cela aboutit un texte représentant une
avancée considérable pour les familles
pour les patients pour la recherche ce
sont bien sûr les dispositions vous
l'avez rappelé relatives à la pma aux
conséquences sur le droit à la filiation
et l'accès aux origines
derrière cela vous le savez il ya autant
de situations humaines parfois de drames
aussi beaucoup d'espoir que nous allons
soulager ou assouvir et nous pouvons en
être fiers
comme vous pouvez comme nous pouvons
être fiers d autres dispositions qui
vont permettre d' importants progrès sur
la recherche scientifique sur les dons
d'organes sur les thérapies je pense
également aux avancées en matière
d'éthique et de l'encadrement d'un
certain nombre de pratiques par exemple
les traitements de données issues de
l'intelligence artificielle pour les
actes de soins
oui mesdames et messieurs les députés
des avancées très significatives et un
équilibre qui a su être trouvé sans
drame sur des sujets dont je n'ignore
pas à la grande sensibilité qui font
miroir aux évolutions de notre société
et interpelle le plus profond de nos
consciences
cet équilibre issue du vote en première
lecture le gouvernement a demandé
solennellement à l'assemblée de l'homme
réserver et c'est bien d'ailleurs parce
que notre volonté est de ne pas
compromettre cet équilibre par des
dispositions autre que mineurs que nous
avons choisi de vous le soumettre en fin
de session extraordinaire la gpa demeure
notre ligne rouge
d'autres sujets s'il vous plaît qui
viendront légitimement un débat d'autres
sujets qui viendront légitimement en
débat dès la réservation des ovocytes
pour le partenaire la pma post moderne
ou encore le diagnostic préimplantatoire
d anne claudie les tests génétiques en
population générale ne recueille auront
bouclé un petit à l'approbation du
gouvernement
un petit logeait de loi cerino dans la
version erian libre et correspondant
parfaitement à la pensée du président de
la république de moi-même va constituer
une avancée majeure et je suis persuadé
que votre assemblée sur de nombreux
bancs en a parfaitement conscience
merci monsieur le premier ministre s'il
vous plaît je vais vous demander un peu
de silence pour écouter à la fois les
questions des collègues et les réponses
du gouvernement
la parole est à monsieur jean louis
bricout et à lui seul merci merci
monsieur président ma question s'adresse
à madame la ministre de l'économie et
concerne le secteur de la grande
distribution du bricolage adeo
maison-mère de leroy merlin welcome et
brico made a décidé de basculer une
bonne partie de ses approvisionnements
en chine l'entreprise nespoli forte de
ses 230 salariés installée en thiérache
à la capelle dans ma circonscription et
fabricants de rouleaux pinceaux brosses
en fait les frais et se voit donc privé
de 50% de son carnet de commandes
ce n'est donc pas l'entreprise qui
délocalise sa production mais le réseau
de distribution qui délocalise ses
approvisionnements il ya certes une
nuance mais le résultat est le même
un plan social est à craindre et des
ouvriers sur le carreau un territoire
qui n'avait pas besoin de cela
voilà où nous mène cette course
infernale à la compétitivité mondiale
elle nous mène au dumping social madame
la ministre
quelles mesures comptez vous prendre
pour que nos entreprises continuent de
produire son de territoire merci chers
collègues la parole à madame agnès
pannier-runacher ministre chargé de
l'industrie
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
orrico au travers de votre question qui
concerne l'entreprise nespoli au fond
vous poser la question de la
compétitivité de notre industrie et des
mesures que nous allons prendre pour
faire en sorte que toute la politique
que nous avons menée ces troisièmes ces
trois années
toute la politique que nous avons mené
ces trois dernières années continue à
créer une empreinte industrielle plus
forte et je le rappelle c'est ce
gouvernement qui à recréer de l'emploi
industriel en 2016 un 2017 en 2000 en
2018 et qui a fait en sorte que la
france est aujourd'hui sur la première
marche du podium en matière
d'investissements directs étrangers en
france dans l'industrie
alors monsieur bricout oui vous avez
raison nous allons accompagner le cas
spécifique de l'entreprise nespoli comme
nous le faisons dans toutes les
circonstances avec bruno le maire et
avec elisabeth board
mais nous allons aller plus loin nous
allons travailler à rendre plus
compétitives notre industrie parce que
c'est aussi une question que l'on ne
peut éviter par la baisse massive des
impôts de production 10 milliards
d'euros en 2021 10 milliards d'euros en
nous allons également faire en sorte
d'euros développer de l'industrie par
des projets portés au niveau des
territoires d'industrie sur l'ensemble
de nos territoires avec jacqueline
gourault 200 millions d'euros sont
d'ores et déjà mobilisés pour porter ces
projets qui vont être mises en oeuvre
d'ici la fin de l'année
ils ce sont des projets très concrets
créateurs d'emplois dans la même veine
nous allons continuer à améliorer la
compétitivité de notre industrie par la
simplification
vous connaissez les sites clés en main
c'est comme ça que l'on installe très
facilement de nouveaux sites en trois
mois pour un permis de construire dix
mois pour une autorisation
environnementale car nous sommes dans
des choses concrètes monsieur benchicou
et vous le savez enfin nous allons
réinvestir dans la relocalisation nous
avons un plan d'action vous savez qu'il
y a une trentaine de professionnels et
nous réussirons
vous avez la parole merci monsieur le
président j'ai bien entendu vos propos
dames la ministre certes la france doit
être compétitive innovantes et je crois
qu'on est un peu usé aussi de d'entendre
aux incantations sur l'écologie les
circuits courts la reculée de
relocalisation en france sur la baisse
des impôts de production la suppression
du sf ça ne marche pas l exemple que je
vous ai cité le prouve
il y a un vrai sujet aux frontières sur
les enjeux environnementaux que vous ne
traitez pas on pourrait en dire de même
sur le secteur agricole et les contrats
de libre échange
il ya aussi un vrai problème de
comportement de ces acteurs économiques
donneurs d'ordre plus à vis des prix bas
des marges confortables que des enjeux
environnementaux et de notre
souveraineté
quand allez vous contrarier ses comporte
les comportements de ceux qui préfèrent
le fric à la france et que vous ne
cessez de privilégiés depuis trois ans
merci monsieur le député la parole est à
monsieur olivier falorni
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre de l'intérieur les policiers
les gendarmes français qui ont obéi aux
ordres de leurs supérieurs en mettant en
oeuvre la rafle du vel'd'hiv sont les
ancêtres de ceux qui aujourd'hui avec le
même elles traquent les migrants et les
sans papiers c'est un amalgame abject a
été écrit et lu solennellement par un
maire de la république française
écharpe tricolore sur l'épaule cet
amalgame abject est une double injures
injure aux victimes de ce crime
imprescriptible commis par le régime de
vichy est une injure à l'égard de notre
police républicaine chargées d'appliquer
notre état de droit démocratique
dans un communiqué de regrets de regret
particulièrement cauteleux ce maire a
affirmé répondre je cite à une polémique
agite et par l'extrême droite
et bien mes chers collègues il n'y a pas
besoin d'être d'extrême droite pour être
indigné comme je l'étais moi qui
souligne
moi qui suis d'une gauche républicaine
et laïque et qui n'oublie jamais que les
claques populaires sont les premières
victimes de l'insécurité
et je dois vous dire qu'on évoquant ce
sujet j'ai en mémoire la commission d'
enquête sur les attentats de 2015 dont
j'étais vice président je me souviens de
ces rescapés du bataclan qu'ils étaient
tous fans de hard rock mais qui n'était
pas vraiment fan de la police avant je
me souviens de leur témoignage poignant
et reconnaissants à l'égard des
policiers qui avaient risqué leur propre
vie pour sauver la leur
cette nuit d'horreur là croyez moi mes
chers collègues
tout le monde aimait la police alors
monsieur le ministre la liberté suppose
la sécurité et la sécurité exige une
police contrôler mais aussi une police
respecte et c'est ce que nous vous
demandons monsieur le ministre
merci merci jacques bollègue
la parole est à monsieur gérald darmanin
ministre de l'intérieur monsieur le
président messieurs les députés monsieur
de débuter falorni
inutile de vous dire que je partage les
propos que vous venez de tenir dans cet
hémicycle nuitamment sur les réseaux
sociaux
j'ai découvert comme beaucoup de
français médusés les propos de monsieur
le maire de colombes après avoir regardé
cette vidéo est méfiant des diffusions
internet en ligne
j'ai utilisé le signe et le conditionnel
pour dire que si les propos s'ils
étaient vérifiées propos proprement
scandaleux et insultants pour la
république pas simplement pour les
forces de l'ordre
si les propos de monsieur le maire de
colombes était confirmée alors en tant
que ministre de l'intérieur
après en avoir informé monsieur le
premier ministre je déposerai plainte
ses propos par plusieurs témoins ont été
confirmés le maire de colombes dans un
communiqué a fait savoir qu'on l'avait
mal compris mais je n'ai pas vu des
excuses formulées non pas à l'endroit du
gouvernement ce qui n'a pas beaucoup de
sens mais à l'endroit des forces de
l'ordre et des françaises et des
français qu'il a particulièrement choqué
j'ai donc décidé hier en fin de journée
deux déposé plainte cette plainte
monsieur le député est déposé et la
justice désormais fera son travail j'ai
saisi monsieur procureur de répliques de
nanterre
je me permets de dire quelques mots
cependant monsieur le député parce que
les forces de l'ordre nous protège et
notre travail me semble-t-il de
législateurs de politiques d'hommes
politiques ou de femmes politiques mais
de mise à l'intérieur c'est de protéger
ce qui nous protège et la comparaison
ignoble entre des faits que l'on a tous
ici condamné qui font appel depuis le
président chirac le poids d'une
démonstration unanime de la classe
politique pour expliquer qu
effectivement le régime de vichy avec
les fonctionnaires qui l'ont servi on
trahit l'âme même de la france
cette comparaison à caprices de la
république monsieur le député fait vomir
je remercie merci monsieur le ministre
la parole est à monsieur le président
damien abad
ce président ma question s'adresse à
vous monsieur le premier ministre sur la
bioéthique
on voit bien vous êtes embarrassé et
vous êtes tellement embarrassée que vous
avez préféré répondre d'abord à la
majorité avant de répondre à
l'opposition sur sept sujets pourtant
aussi fondamentale monsieur le premier
ministre c'est votre devoir de nous
répondre de répondre à l'ensemble des
députés la nation mais aussi à
l'ensemble des familles françaises qui
sont aujourd'hui inquiète
elles sont inquiètes monsieur le premier
ministre à l'image des parents de la
jeune adélaïde que j'ai rencontré ce
week-end en ardèche qui sont fiers et
heureux tout simplement de revoir leur
fille pleine de vie et qui s'interrogent
et ne comprennent pas pourquoi votre
majorité s'obstine à vouloir maintenir
l'article 19 sur le diagnostic
préimplantatoire et la détection
systématique de ce diagnostic accepté
accepté ce diagnostic pour tout les
trisomiques et surtout pour la trisomie
c'est faire un premier pas et vous le
savez madame busin l'a dit elle-même
vers le tri des embryons
mes chers collègues vous ne pouvez pas
jouer à la roulette russe avec les
embryons vous ne pouvez pas jouer aux
apprentis sorciers sur des questions
aussi fondamentales que la vie humaine
alors monsieur prémices dites-nous les
choses clairement dites nous si oui ou
non c'est vous qui allait l'emporter en
retirant cet article ou est ce que c'est
votre majorité qui va le maintenir coûte
que coûte
dites nous la vérité et dites nous si
vous allez retirer cette mesure
potentiellement dangereuses et
particulièrement offensante pour les
familles d'enfants atteints de trisomie
merci monsieur le président la parole à
monsieur le premier ministre monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
députés
monsieur le président abad j'ai en effet
répondu tout à l'heure à cette question
très importante sur le projet de loi
bioéthique et je crois avoir précisé de
la manière la plus claire
quelle était la position du gouvernement
sur ce sujet peut-être qu'elle
que interventions intempestives vous
ont-elles empêché d'entendre
l'intégralité de mon propos ma position
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés qui est celle
évidemment de l'ensemble du gouvernement
est que nous demandons en deuxième
lecture et dans le cadre des discussions
normales qui se dérouleront dans cet
hémicycle dans le respect des
interventions de chacune et de chacun
d'en rester le plus possible au texte
qui ici même a été votée en octobre 2019
c'est clair net et précis pourquoi
pourquoi parce que c'est un texte qui a
été profondément concertée qui a été
profondément débattue qui est jean
félicite toutes celles et ceux qui ont
contribué a permis a permis de
progresser par rapport au texte
gouvernemental
en tenant compte de différentes
contributions y compris d'ailleurs
venant de vaud bord c'est un texte
équilibré
je le répète et je vous invite à toutes
et à tous à ne pas vous éloigner de cet
équilibre et la majorité et la majorité
et la main revendre et j'en suis
persuadé partagera cette volonté nous
sommes monsieur le président abad devant
la nécessité de comprendre les
évolutions de notre société
nous sommes également devant la
nécessité d'apaiser cette société
d'apaiser cette société et je passe et
je pense comme vous toutes et vous tous
que c'est ce chemin que vous suivrez
dans quelques jours j'écoute je parle d'
équilibre monsieur abad j'écoute dans la
fonction qui est désormais la sienne
les évolutions de la société
je m'inscris avec la majorité
parlementaire dans une démarche de
progrès j'ai un fermi l'autorité de
l'état et la laïcité de la république je
construis le dialogue social et la
libération des territoires
merci monsieur le premier ministre la
parole est à mme adam dunn a par
monsieur va c'est bon c'est bon si vous
parliez moins fort j'aurais entendu
monsieur abad
vous avez la parole cher collègue
monsieur le premier ministre je vous
entends mais votre majorité
elle est pour votre ministre la santé a
voté pour en première lecture
vos rapporteurs sont quasiment tous pour
et donc la question qui est centrale c
est ce que aujourd'hui on est sûr et
certain qu'on n'ira pas dans cette
dérive là que les français ne veulent
pas que personne ne veut et quitte une
dérive terry pour la société française
et au delà de slam se prémunissent sur
la question également des chimères alors
tout simplement ce prêt vise la
bioéthique
elles méritent mieux que du slogan elle
mérite de l'humilité merci la parole est
à madame danielle brulebois merci
monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur ministre des
solidarités de la santé monsieur le
ministre les accords de ségur de la
santé dont vous avez présenté les
conclusions la semaine dernière ont été
quelque peu éclipsé le même jour par le
plan de relance européen qui est un
événement majeur et fondateur pour
l'europe qui nous est cher les accords
du ségur de la santé sont cependant eux
aussi des accords historiques
ils viennent reconnaître l'engagement de
ceux qui nous soignent avec 8 milliard
deux cents millions d'euros
d'amélioration des salaires de l'hôpital
public et privé ce sont des sommes sans
précédent qui viennent valoriser les
métiers et l'engagement des soignants en
première ligne pendant la crise dont
salle une nouvelle fois le dévouement
exemplaire malgré toutes les promesses
faites depuis des décennies jamais un
gouvernement n'aura autant fait en
matière de reconnaissance de ces métiers
de santé tellement essentiel pour notre
société et chacun d'entre nous c'est un
rattrapage considérable que vous avez
menées monsieur le ministre
par rapport à des années de retard et
d'inaction au delà des revalorisations
des salaires monsieur le ministre vous
voulez faire confiance à l'hôpital et
aux acteurs de terrain
en consacrant 19 milliards d'euros à
l'investissement pour améliorer la prise
en charge des patients et le quotidien
des soignants je vous ai fait parvenir
les contributions des acteurs de santé
du jura que vous m'avez chargé de
remercier je sais qu'ils ont retenu
toute votre attention monsieur le
ministre pouvez vous nous dire comment
les élus locaux seront associés à
l'appréciation des besoins en santé et
commencera redonner du pouvoir aux
territoires en matière d'investissement
l'annnonce de l'ouverture de 4000 lits
et la création de quinze mille emplois à
lever les plus grands espoirs
comment ces décisions vont elles se
décliner dans lé groupement hospitalier
les hôpitaux de proximité les services
d'urgence les 6 pts et les ehpad de nos
départements ruraux
je vous remercie merci chers collègues
la parole à monsieur olivier ferrand
ministre des solidarités et de la santé
madame la députée danielle brulebois
merci pour cette question qui permet de
revenir sur
sur les accords du ségur et sur le
contenu des propositions que nous avons
pu formuler à l'issue d'un travail
conduit sous l'égide du premier ministre
vous l'avez dit madame la députée les
soignants que nous ont-ils demandé nous
ont demandé la juste reconnaissance de
leur travail et nous avons débloqué 8
milliards d'euros 8,2 milliards d'euros
par an par an revaloriser tous les
salaires de tous les métiers de
l'hôpital public privé et de tous les
ehpad
c'est la première fois et c'est 40 fois
plus d'argent sur la table par an que
les derniers accords hospitalier qui
avait eu lieu mais soyons nous ont dit
nous manquons de lits à l'hôpital
nous avons des brancards dans les
services d'urgence nous avons parfois
une fluctuation d'activité pendant les
épidémies ou dans les zones à forte
densité de population pendant les
vacances notamment qui fait que nous
n'avons plus à soigner correctement les
patients nous avons décidé l'ouverture
de 4000 lits à la demande
c'est la première fois qu'un discours
comme celui ci est tenu depuis plus de
15 ans madame la députée oui nous sommes
capables de dire qu'il peut manquer
délit et nous en ouvrons les soignants
d'aujourd'hui nous ne sommes pas assez
nombreux pour faire correctement des
soins avec bientraitance pour pouvoir
prendre le temps d'être au lit du malade
et lorsqu'il ya des absences dans les
équipes et bien c'est toute l'équipe qui
est mobilisée ce sont les infirmières
qu'on va bouger d'un service à un autre
nous avons répondu par la création de
quinze mille postes de soignants
supplémentaires quinze mille postes de
soignants supplémentaires tout en
redonnant l'attractivité au métier pour
faire en sorte qu'il n'y ait plus de
postes vacants dans les hôpitaux et
soignants nous on dit il ya trop de
bureaucratie trop de normes c'est trop
compliqué on n'y arrive plus nous avons
rendu facultative un grand nombre de
normes et de règles nous avons permis là
où il le souhaitait la re création des
services hospitaliers pour avoir plus
d'actions de proximité
et puisque vous m'interrogez sur la
place des élus et des territoires
moi je souhaite qu'un élu quand ils
passent la porte une agence régionale de
santé ils puissent se sentir chez lui
les ars font un travail formidable nous
devons renforcer leur présence au niveau
départemental pour travailler davantage
avec l'ensemble des élus pour qu'ils
puissent participer pleinement aux
politiques d'investissement et de
développement de la santé sur les
territoires
c'est aussi ça ce que prône le
gouvernement de jean castex et nous
l'avons fait
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
un monsieur olivier marc l'ex merci
monsieur le président le chef premier
ministre chacun sur nos bords j'en suis
sûr pourrait faire siens les mots d'aimé
césaire qualifiant la traite et
l'esclavagé de sauvagerie insurpassée au
cours des siècles
chacun sur nos bornes regarde avec
fierté le vote unanime qui fut celui de
l'assemblée nationale il ya tout juste
vingt ans à l'initiative de madame
taubira reconnaissant la traite et
l'esclavagé comme un crime contre
l'humanité
chacun sur nos bancs salue la décision
qui fut celle de jacques chirac
d'instituer une journée mémorial le 10
mai et constate avec lui que la
république s'est construite avec le
combat abolitionniste et nous avons été
aussi je crois un nombreux sur ses bancs
a salué les propos du président macron
le 14 juin dernier lorsqu'il affirmait
la république n'effacera aucune trace ni
aucun nom de son histoire la république
ne déboulonnera aucune statue il y a il
aura en réalité fallu un petit mois
seulement pour que la parole
présidentielle atteigne sa péremption
puisque ce dimanche 26 juillet un petit
groupe d'activistes à fort de france a
détruit aux termes d'un ultimatum d'un
ultimatum si le regard passif de l'état
sur les fenêtres même de la préfecture
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur une
statue de joséphine de beauharnais
comment votre gouvernement avertit par
ultimatum at il pu laisser faire comment
votre gouvernement
informé à l'avancé at il pu laisser
détruire un monument historique seront
dans juridiquement complice par
abstention d'un délit puni de 10 ans de
prison
par quelle faiblesse avait voulu
renoncer aussi vite à tenir une promesse
du chef de l'état où était monsieur le
premier ministre
l'autorité de votre gouvernement
dimanche dernier à fort de france
merci je collègues la parole est à
monsieur gérald darmanin ministre de
l'intérieur
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
marc l'ex comme vous évidemment nous
partageons le fait que non seulement la
république a été a été l'institution qui
a permis à l'abolition et les
territoires notamment ultramarins dans
la république qui avait les mêmes
égalité de droits que les habitants qui
était sur le sol métropolitain et comme
vous nous reconnaissons bien sûr comme
vous l'avait dit et sont plusieurs
majorités publiques politiques sont
plusieurs gouvernements le fait qu
évidemment les esclavages et la chose
une des choses les plus horribles que
pourrait commettre d'humanité sur ce
point nous sommes d'accord vous avez là
des d'accord monsieur le député ceux des
propos du président de la république
c'est assez rare pour le souligner ça
doit vous demander un effort important
là où nous sommes un peu moins d'accord
monsieur le député
[Applaudissements]
s'il vous plaît quand je regrette jean
je regrette que vous avez perdu votre
légendaire sens de l'humour collectif là
où je regrette monsieur le député c'est
que vous êtes inquiet les représentants
vous attaquez les représentants de
l'état
monsieur le député qui ont fait leur
travail en martinique
à commencer par monsieur le préfet que
je veux ici saluer et remercier et les
forces de l'ordre qui ont protégé la
préfecture au moment où un groupuscule
incendiaires attaqué des bâtiments
publics et au moment où monsieur le
député où ils se prenaient en pleine
journée
dès 9h30 du matin justement pour qu'on
en parle monsieur le député et le préfet
non seulement à condamner ces actes a
déposé auprès de la justice des plats
desserts pour la poursuite de cela et
est intervenu pour que dans les rues de
fort de france il n'existe pas ce que
vous venez d'évoquer c'est à dire le
chaos la protection des populations
vous avez oublié de dire monsieur le
député que ce groupuscule qui est suivi
par les services du ministère de
l'intérieur que ce groupuscule s'en est
pris également à la statue de monsieur
gandhi le qualifiant de négrophobe
montrant ainsi que ces extrémistes
doivent être poursuivis et condamnés et
la martinique n'a pas eu à rougir de
représentants de l'état et leurs
interventions
c'est plus facile sans doute à faire ici
mais monsieur le député marc avec sauver
la parole réalité monsieur le ministre
ce que dimanche dernier vous avez laissé
faire il n'y avait sur place
nick dit forces de l'ordre ni corps
préfectoral en matière de sécurité - de
mots plus d'action écouter un peu plus
les conseils de nicolas sarkozy on n'en
fait jamais assez merci monsieur
la parole est à mme cécile untermaier
monsieur monsieur le premier ministre le
rapport gréco du conseil de l'europe
publié le 9 janvier dernier fait état de
persistance de zones grises au sein de
l'exécutif en france c'est pas nouveau
après remaniement votre gouvernement
compte 43 ministres et conseillers
d'état et potentiellement 5 163
conseillers
il s'agit sans doute du gouvernement le
plus important en nombre est le plus
élevé en coût de la vème république
sa gouvernance exige de tendre vers une
exemplarité d'autant plus difficile à
garantir que le nombre d'intervenants
est élevé aujourd'hui seuls demeurent au
gouvernement les règles imposées par les
lois du 11 octobre 2013
la déontologie a fait son entrée dans
les grandes institutions dans la
magistrature et au sein des grandes
collectivités territoriales comme de son
administration
elle doit d'ailleurs à mon sens évoluer
davantage vers le conseil que vers le
contrôle en amont et en aval des
obligations de déclaration d'intérêts
patrimoine
les ministres sont confrontés aux
questions à des pressions et comme le
conseiller mérite comme partout ailleurs
d'être accompagné prévenu conseillé par
une instance déontologique
il s'agit d'éviter les affaires du passé
tels la sphère delevoye dernier exemple
en date détecter les situations de
conflits d'intérêts de déport en conseil
des ministres ou dans les commissions et
sans doute aussi renseigner sans la
tyrannie de la transparence
les frais de représentation ce n'est pas
le rôle du sgg mais d'une personne
identifiée au sein de votre exécutif en
responsabilité et dans la transparence
l'observatoire de l'éthique publique
présidée par rené dosière a fait une
proposition en ce sens qui a reçu un
écho très favorable
allez vous monsieur le premier ministre
vous engager dans cette voie d'une
gouvernance introduisant pour la
première fois cette culture
déontologique de conseils de prévention
des risques
elle est au demeurant est essentielle à
la relation de confiance avec les
citoyens
bien la parole à monsieur eric
dupond-moretti garde des sceaux ministre
de la justice monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs les députés
madame la députée une terme ailleurs
avant de vous répondre je voudrais
rendre hommage devant la représentation
nationale au nom du gouvernement
en tant que garde des sceaux mais aussi
en tant qu'ancien avocat et finalement
en tant que citoyens à mettre gisèle
halimi qui nous a quittés ce matin
toute sa vie elle aura combattu
elle aura à militer elle aura mesdames
et messieurs défendu son obsession était
la justice pour tous et je devrais dire
peut-être la justice pour toutes
à cet instant toutes mes pensées celle
du gouvernement vont à sa famille et à
ses proches
madame madame le député une terme
ailleurs il mais rappelé que le temps
est compté alors vous savez que le
pouvoir exécutif a été doté par la loi
depuis plusieurs années d'outils
destinés à veiller à l'ado déontologie
des membres du gouvernement je vais pas
vous rappeler les lois d'octobre 2013 de
décembre 2016 de septembre 2017 les lois
n'ont cessé de renforcer les outils de
prévention déontologique la déontologie
des membres du gouvernement est placée
sous le contrôle de la haute autorité
pour la transparence de la vie publique
elle est chargée de superviser la
procédure de vérification et je vous
réponds et ensuite des membres les
membres du gouvernement lui adressent
leur déclaration de situation
patrimoniale
je tiens toutefois à rappeler qu'il est
nécessaire que sur ces sujets nous
réfléchissions ensemble aux limites que
nous souhaitons nous fixer il est
indispensable que les dirigeants du pays
ses plus hauts représentants donnent
l'exemple
mais il ne faudrait pas tomber dans les
travers inverse où la transperce ans je
devrais dire la transparence
découragerait les générations prête à
s'engager pour réformer notre pays
craignant madame pour leur vie privée
leurs proches et surtout d'être livré à
la vindicte populaire comme 'pourris'
lâché jadis les chiens à quand madame la
députée le déontologue de la déontologie
merci monsieur le garde des sceaux
la parole est un monsieur erwan balanant
avant de poser ma question merci merci
monsieur le garde des sceaux pour ses
mots pour sceller moat envers cette
combattante de la république
cette combattante des libertés cette
combattante de la justice à la rentrée
nous allons examiner un texte important
pour nos institutions le pl le pgi lots
de réforme du conseil économique social
et environnemental
le cesu endosse aujourd'hui endosse
aujourd'hui principalement un rôle de
conseiller du gouvernement et du
parlement en vue de l'élaboration de la
politique nationale en matière
économique sociale et environnementale
sa composition ses modalités de
fonctionnement et le rythme des réformes
met à mal le plein accomplissement de
ses missions plus généralement cette
chambre méconnu du grand public est
souvent mal aimé des élus voit son
utilité remise en cause
pourtant cette institution est un outil
de consultation citoyenne primordial et
le récent succès de la convention
citoyenne pour le climat porté par le
cse en est une illustration éloquente
cette expérience démocratique inédite
ouvrent de nombreuses pistes de
réflexion pour une rénovation
démocratique
alors en ce sens le projet de loi
organique dont nous débattrons à la
rentrée prochaine est porteur d'une
vraie ambition et au delà de sa mission
actuelle il assurera le traitement des
pétitions dans un cadre modernisé et
surtout il deviendra le carrefour des
consultations publiques cvo ces
évolutions seront cruciales pour faire
vivre la démocratie participative c'est
nous en sommes convaincus au groupe
modem l'une des meilleure façon de
réconcilier les français avec la
démocratie représentative et donc
améliorer le fonctionnement de notre
démocratie tout court
alors monsieur le ministre au delà de la
réforme
ne devons-nous pas travailler sur de
nouvelles perspectives pour articuler
cette démocratie participative souhaité
par les français et les françaises et la
démocratie représentative piliers de
notre république
merci la parole à monsieur eric
dupond-moretti garde des sceaux ministre
de la justice monsieur monsieur s'il
vous plaît monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs les députés
monsieur le député erwan balanant je
connais votre intérêt et celui de tous
ceux qui sont ici d'ailleurs sur cette
question j'étais moi-même eu hier devant
vous pour vous demander d'adopter un
projet de loi organique qui nous
permettra de débattre sur le fond dès le
mois de septembre ce projet il a pour
vocation vous le savez de donner de
nouveaux moyens à cette assemblée
consultative dans le but de renforcer
comme vous l'avez mentionné la
démocratie participative qui a besoin en
somme d'oxygène alors je pense
qu'effectivement le cee peut-être lé
instrument de ce renforcement
ce projet de loi ne modifie pas les
compétences du cee d'ailleurs pour cela
il faudrait modifier la constitution
en revanche ils modifient les moyens à
la disposition du saison en particulier
le cse pourra organiser la participation
du public et s'adjoindre des citoyens
pour l'aider dans la préparation de cet
avis l'actrice des gilet jaune
le grand débat national la convention
citoyenne pour le climat l'ont montré
nos concitoyens aspire à être mieux
associés et à participer plus
directement aux décisions publiques et
nous devons répondre à cette attente je
voudrais toutefois rassuré sur un point
essentiel renforcer la démocratie
participative ne signifie pas affaiblir
la démocratie participative
représentative dont vous êtes à la fois
le symbole est le garant le cee est et
demeurera une assemblée consultative
composée de représentants des forces
économiques et sociales du pays et
chargés d'éclairer les pouvoirs publics
sur les enjeux économiques sociaux
environnementaux de notre temps il n'y a
donc aucune concurrence avec les
assemblées du parlement composée de
représentants élus de la nation qui
votent la loi et contrôler l'action du
gouvernement
pas de concurrence en particulier avec
l'assemblée nationale devant laquelle le
gouvernement est responsable
merci monsieur le ministre la parole à
monsieur pierre dharréville monsieur le
premier ministre je dis une nappe de
chlorure ferrique c'est écoulés dans la
mer depuis le site pétrochimique moines
de lavéra cet incident a suscité une
vive émotion
1 la suppression des chsct n'est pas
sans effet sur les enjeux de sécurité et
de santé
une proposition de loi existe pour déjà
rétablir des instances dans les sites
seveso à la suite de l'accident de
lubrizol et de tous les autres je vous
demande d'y réfléchir
2 après deux arrêtés de mise en demeure
en 2019 la responsabilité de
l'entreprise est engagée sur la
maintenance et la surveillance
avait-elle assez investi sur cette
partie non productifs des installations
ou de la duck moines où il faut
reconnaître des travaux importants ces
dernières années l'investissement dans
l'outil industriel n'est souvent pas à
la hauteur parce que cela vient
contrarier la quête de dividendes l'état
doit exiger les transformations
nécessaires à la protection des salariés
population et environnement les leviers
de l'intervention publique semble
aujourd'hui insuffisant 3 vous avez
écrit monsieur le premier ministre hier
dans ouest france que près du tiers des
investissements prévus par le plan de
relance sera directement dédiée à la
conversion écologique de notre économie
tout apport doit être conditionné et ne
doit pas être utilisé pour maintenir le
taux de rémunération des actions mais
pour permettre à l'état de peser
durablement tout appelle une gestion
démocratiser de ces fonds au regard des
enjeux économiques écologiques
sanitaires et sociaux les grandes
concentrations doit avoir une place
particulière dans ce plan je dépose donc
la candidature de l'un des plus grands
sites industriels d'europe le port
industriel de fos-sur-mer
y compris d'ailleurs pour y développer
le fret nous voulons une transition
écologique de l'industrie
vous avez écrit l'écologie à laquelle je
crois et celle de l'action plutôt que de
l'incantation quelle suite allez-vous
donner à l'incident de lavéra vous avez
là une occasion à saisir
merci monsieur débuté la parole devant
la barbara pompili ministre de la
transition écologique
merci merci monsieur le président
monsieur le député pierre dharréville
effectivement il ya une fuite qui
provenait d'un bac de production de
chlorure ferrique qui a été détectée la
semaine dernière et qui est et qui
venait de l'installation de l'exploitant
qu'est moines
alors cette fuite a provoqué une
pollution dans lens doggett qui
heureusement a été circonscrite
j'ai eu l'occasion d'échanger dès
vendredi évidemment avec le maire de
martigues gaby charroux que vous
connaissez à qui évidemment j'ai
confirmé que le gouvernement était très
vigilant sur les suites de cette affaire
l'inspection des installations classées
à ses rangs du sursis tout de suite et à
vérifier que l'exploitant mettez en
oeuvre les moyens nécessaires pour
supprimer la fuite parce que avant de
parler de l'avenir il faut d'abord
parler de ce qui se passe maintenant par
précaution la baignade a été interdite
jusqu'à samedi dernier mais a été
aujourd'hui réautoriser sur les plages
donc à ce stade il n'y a pas de
mortalité piscicole mais on reste
mobilisé et d'adrien évidemment analyse
les risques d co toxicité le préfet a
signé vendredi un arrêt un arrêté
d'urgence pour imposer à l'exploitant la
mise en sécurité des installations un
rapport d'accident sous 15 jours
une surveillance dans les prochaines
semaines de l'impact sur la partie
terrestre et pas seulement marine une
surveillance à court terme et à moyen
terme de l'impact sur la partie maritime
et l'évaluation d'impact sur les mines
sur les milieux en lien avec un expert
compétents et bien sûr le nettoyage des
zones concernées je peux vous assurer
que l'exploitant devra nettoyer les
dommages et compenser des pertes en
matière de biodiversité
si nécessaire et comme le prévoit la loi
et je peux vous assuré monsieur le
député que la plus grande transparence
sera faite sur ces affaires et que nous
allons profiter du plan de relance pour
effectivement faire en sorte que
l'industrie nécessaire dans notre pays
puisse être conciliée avec la
préservation de notre environnement et
et aussi de nos enjeux climatiques
le plan de relance sera l'occasion et
nous allons y mettre les moyens
madame la ministre la parole de monsieur
jean-jacques ferrara merci merci
monsieur le président en l'absence de la
ministre des armées qui est à tarbes
monsieur le président je ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
monsieur le premier ministre
quoi que l'on puisse penser du plan de
relance européen il a fait deux victimes
le fonds européen de défense fixé à 7
milliards contre très espéré et l'espace
dont le budget est passé de 16 milliards
d'euros espérés attrait et quelques ces
mauvaises nouvelles ont pour nous deux
conséquence directe d'une part elles
viennent percuter de plein fouet
l'ambition affichée de l'europe de
conquérir son autonomie stratégique
objectif cher au président de la
république
d'autre part c'est autant de financement
moins pour nos industries de défense et
spatial
ce qui constitue une faute stratégique
et une erreur économique
ce constat nous avons été plusieurs à le
formuler devant la commission de la
défense
surtout les banques l'industrie de
souveraineté constitue l'un des
meilleurs canaux de transmission de
l'effort de relance
elle crée des emplois sans délai elle
tire vers le haut la recherche
technologique et enfin elle est
essentiellement nationales et
européennes bien sûr les plus candides
préfère voir le verre à moitié plein
pour eux après tout une partie de ces
financements sont inédits mais c'est
tout 13 milliards nous sommes bien loin
des 300 milliards que l'administration
américaine consacre à la défense
alors monsieur le premier ministre
comment se réjouir de telles annonces
comment ne pas y voir une occasion
manquée comment enfin croire que la
défense constitue bel et bien une
priorité pour nos partenaires européens
[Applaudissements]
merci chers collègues la parole de
madame geneviève darrieussecq ministre
délégué auprès de la ministre des armées
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les députés
monsieur le député ferrara permettez moi
effectivement d'excusés florence parly
qui est à tarbes actuellement à
l'hommage aux soldats hussards
parachutistes razafintsalama pour lequel
la représentation nationale a eu un
moment d'émotion en début de séance et
je dois vous dire que la reconnaissance
de la nation est très important pour nos
armées qui sont toujours très affectés
dans ces moments difficiles et le
sacrifice suprême de nos soldats nous
oblige
alors opposé une question importante sur
le budget de la défense ce budget de la
défense
d'abord vous l'avez dit il est inédit il
n'existait pas il a été proposé par la
commission européenne
il a été proposé vous l'avez dit
également 1 13 milliard d'euros c'était
avant la crise du coc vide et il a été
là décidée à 7 milliards d'euros ce qui
correspond d'ailleurs à la dernière
proposition de monsieur charles michel
moi je suis je vois le verre à moitié
plein monsieur le député je vois le
verre à moitié plein parce que c'est une
c'est une création budgétaire absolument
historique au niveau de la défense
c'est une création budgétaire qui nous
permettra progressivement de travailler
vers notre autonomie stratégique en
terme de défense au niveau européen de
travailler vers des programmes
d'innovation et de recherche toujours
plus pertinents et vous savez que la
coopération structurée qui est à la base
de nombreux projets de de recherche dans
la défense et bien pourra être financé
vous savez également que l'opérationnel
avec par exemple l'opération takouba et
bien se constitue aussi
donc pour nous gouvernement pour nous au
ministère de la désarmer et bien c'est
absolument historique et nous allons
continuer bien entendu avec nos
collègues européens
merahi ministre au pouvoir
la défense aura la parole
madame la ministre je vais vous faire
part de ma crainte il ne faudrait pas
que ces fonds européens viennent
ponctionner les budgets nationaux des
états membres en faveur de la défense
merci la parole est à madame danielle
obono nes merci monsieur le président
les enfants sont les principales
victimes de violences sexuelles
chaque année 130 milles filles et 35000
gars ont subi ce viol et tentative de
viol
une fille sur cinq et un garçon sur 13
ans sont victimes 80% de l'ensemble des
violences sexuelles des buts avant 18
ans 51% avant onze ans 21% avant 6 ans
ni la société ni les institutions de
sont à la hauteur face à ces crimes
pour plus des deux tiers des victimes le
fait d'avoir parlé n'a entraîné aucune
conséquence leur prise en charge médico
psychologique est notoirement
insuffisantes
tout comme la protection judiciaire et
les suites données à ces crimes
gabriel matzneff mis en cause par
vanessa singora qui a subi ces abus à
l'âge de 14 ans a sévi pendant des
décennies en toute impunité au vu et au
su du soi-disant beau monde
non seulement cela mais il a été encensé
est célébrée pour avoir écrit des livres
oui glorifiait ces crimes ainsi en 2013
il reçoit le prix renaudot essai qu'il
considère comme une récompense pour
l'ensemble de son oeuvre
je nous épargnerait la lecture de
certains passages de cette oeuvre en
il a fallu plusieurs semaines pour que
sous la pression d'associations
le parquet se saisisse du dossier du
pédocriminels jeffrey epstein dont les
ramifications françaises sont pourtant
connus depuis plusieurs années le
silence l'impunité sont les meilleures
armes des prédateurs il faut y mettre un
terme
alors monsieur le ministre de la justice
c'est toi d'ignorer vous répondre à la
question que je vous ai posé la semaine
dernière lors de votre audition en
commission des lois concernant la
politique que vous comptez mener et les
moyens que vous comptez mettre en oeuvre
pour assurer que justice soit rendue aux
victimes de ces crimes
seriez vous prêt également à envisager
d'adopter la proposition que nous avons
déposée concernant la présomption simple
de non consentement qui en renversant la
charge de la preuve en faveur des
enfants victimes de violences sexuelles
constituerait un progrès notable du
droit
la parole de monsieur eric
dupond-moretti garde des sceaux ministre
de la justice
mesdames messieurs les députés madame la
députée la justice voyez-vous n'est
jamais aussi grande que quand elle se
préoccupe du sort des tout-petits et les
enfants sont les tout petits qu'on les
traite au travers des différentes
législations dont celle que vous appelez
de vos voeux qu'on les traite dans la
législation à venir sur la bioéthique
les tout petits doivent eux mérité bien
sûr toute notre attention
pourtant madame pour autant madame le
député
il existe déjà un certain nombre de loin
qui ne demande qu'à être appliquer des
lois qui répriment évidemment les
comportements des pédocriminels ou des
pédophiles qui les répriment et qui
envisage éventuellement leur sortie
quand l'heure est arrivée avec des suivi
socio judiciaire
il existe aussi madame que vous le
vouliez ou non un certain nombre de
mesures qui protègent les enfants
bien sûr et c'est heureux alors vous
proposer un nid plus ni moins qu'un
renversement de la charge de la preuve
c'est déjà une idée qui a fleuri dans
quelques esprits il n'est pas possible
valable de renverser la charge de la
preuve
mais il est possible en revanche d'être
extrêmement attentifs au recueil de la
parole des enfants
je pourrais vous en parler longuement
j'ai beaucoup travaillé après l affaire
d'outreau sur la façon dont il convenait
de recueillir la parole des enfants il
faut qu'interviennent des magistrats des
policiers des gendarmes extrêmement
compétents formés pour recueillir la
parole de l'enfant tant il est vrai que
cela est éminemment fragile éminemment
complexe et madame sachez que notre
justice contrairement à ce que vous
pouvez dire ne laisse pas filer ce quand
il est avéré qu'une preuve de leur
culpabilité a été recueilli dans un
processus judiciaire qui permettaient
moi madame de vous le dire
respectueusement nous honore
merci monsieur mais il ne s'agit pas de
moi il s'agit des milliers et des
milliers et des milliers de victimes qui
régulièrement témoigne sur les réseaux
sociaux des faillites et des
défaillances
on parle on parle de la fin de la parole
des enfants devenus adultes
merci pour voir si la parole est à
monsieur françois jolivet et à lui seul
merci merci monsieur le président
monsieur milieu intérieur la garantie
des droits de l'homme et du citoyen
nécessite une force publique
c'est ce qui a érigé comme principe le
législateur
si vous avez une discussion à conduire
vous sortez
sinon vous écoutez le seul orateur qui a
la parole notre collègue jolivet s'il
vous plaît vous avez la parole et vous
seuls avez la parole
merci monsieur le président je vous ai
deux je vous disais donc que le
législateur de 1789 avait considéré que
la garantie des droits de l'homme et du
citoyen nécessité une force publique
pour lui sans sécurité pas de liberté
cette force publique aujourd'hui
baptisée forces de l'ordre aux forces de
sécurité intérieure rassemble des femmes
et des hommes qui ont pour mission de
rassurer de protéger et de sauver de
tout temps en tout lieu sur tous les
fronts elles agissent sur le fond de
l'ordre public elles font face à des
situations violentes lusage récent de
mortiers d'artifice contre elle en
témoignent les actes violents de fin de
manifestations deviennent maintenant
récurrent sur le fond de la sécurité du
quotidien elles deviennent des cibles
sur le fond social
elles sont le réceptacle de bien des
malaises individuel et collectif
elles sont par ailleurs devenues les
otages d'un magma médiatique et
politique
les juges ont aidé condamnant avant même
l'ouverture d' enquête
si les dérives de quelques-uns ne sont
pas contestables
cela ne doit pas jeter l'opprobre sur
l'extrême majorité d'entre eux cette
majorité a besoin d'être rassuré et de
retrouver le sens de sa mission et de sa
vocation elle a besoin de votre soutien
de celui du gouvernement monsieur
ministre jérôme mathias
alexis maggie pascal mathieu ludovic
frédéric ollivier marielle sont des
prénoms parmi d'autres de policiers qui
ont mis fin à leur vie parce que leur
métier sans doute évolué beaucoup la
prise en compte du risque du suicide
doit devenir désormais un souci
permanent de la ligne hiérarchique le
suicide d'un membre des forces de
l'ordre ne doit pas devenir une habitude
sourde
aussi monsieur le ministre comment
entendez-vous avec monsieur le premier
ministre ont donné un sens lisible de
leurs actions aux forces de l'ordre
et comment entendez vous prévenir le
risque du suicide de celles et ceux qui
nous protège merci chers collègues la
parole est à monsieur gérald darmanin
ministre de l'intérieur monsieur le
président les députés monsieur le député
jolivet vous avez raison les forces de
l'ordre comme beaucoup de professions
mais singulièrement les policiers les
gendarmes vous avez raison de souligner
connaissent des difficultés qui sont
propres à leur métier
quand des conséquences très importantes
sur la vie de famille et sur leur vie
personnelle et les mène souvent à des
questionnements sur leurs engagements et
parfois dans des circonstances
particulièrement dramatiques à mettre
fin à leurs jours
mes prédécesseurs sous plusieurs
gouvernements ont essayé d'endiguer ce
problème d'autant plus difficile que les
cycles horaires des policiers et des
gendarmes
la violence à laquelle ils sont
confrontés les mutations notamment de
sortie d'école qu'il l'aimait loin de
leur famille et parfois de leurs jeunes
familles les pousse parfois à connaître
cette dépression auquel nous devons
absolument répondre
beaucoup de choses ont été faites
beaucoup de choses restent à faire
c'est pourquoi j'ai souhaité vous dire
aujourd'hui suite à votre interpellation
que l'une des raisons pour lesquelles
les policiers les gendarmes peuvent être
falloir jours c'est effectivement les
les blessures les agressions les
attaques soient physiques ou verbales ou
mental qui peuvent dont ils peuvent
faire l'objet
ils doivent en parler et nous avons
parlé auprès de leur hiérarchie et
auprès du ministère de l'intérieur et
donc un dispositif qui a été élaboré par
mon prédécesseur que je mets en place
après consultation des syndicats
pour les policiers pour les gendarmes
victime sera mis en place dès le début
du mois prochain qui permettra à toute
heure dans plusieurs façons de
télédéclarations ou au téléphone de
pouvoir lorsqu'on est policier victime
joindre immédiatement quelqu'un du
ministère de l'intérieur pour a suivi
bien plus individuelle qui ne l'est
aujourd'hui pour les accompagner dans
les difficultés personnelles ou
professionnelles
mais vous l'avez dit monsieur le député
il s'agit aussi du soutien du sens que
l'on donne aux agents du service public
qui donne parfois leur vie pour la
protection de nos concitoyens et je suis
comme vous monsieur le député entre un
policier et quelqu'un qui a commis des
méfaits qui sont contraires aux lois de
la république ne choisiront toujours le
policier jour merci merci monsieur le
ministre
la parole est à monsieur sébastien chenu
monsieur le premier ministre
le plan de relance adopté par l'union
européenne est pour la france
le pire accord possible il signifie
endettement colossal tutelle budgétaire
renforcée et ouvre la perspective d'un
futur impôt européen
comment qualifier d'historique un accord
qui sonne comme un échec personnel du
président macron bien incapable de
négocier avec nos partenaires européens
et impuissants à défendre l'intérêt de
la france qui le motive si peu si tout
plan de relance nécessite d'investir et
de dépenser il n'y avait aucune
obligation à recourir à une dette
commune
nous subissons la double peine d'un côté
nous devrons donc contribué un fonds
dont nous perdrons la maîtrise
d'affectation et de l'autre nous serons
contributeurs déficitaire c'est à dire
que nous continuerons à payer pour les
autres
en particulier ceux qui ont fait le
choix de réindustrialiser leur pays en
touchant que 40 milliards de ce plan la
france est le dindon de la farce
elles représentent 17 % du budget
européen et elle va toucher simplement
10 % des aides
cet emprunt commun va endetter
lourdement les jeunes générations et de
l'aveu même du ministre l'économie nul
ne connaît la clé de répartition du
remboursement au niveau européen sept
accords est au mieux aventuriers au pire
il est inconséquent et bien le maquereau
va donc restreindre nos capacités
financières et renforcer notre
dépendance budgétaire au nom du
fédéralisme européen
son grand fantasme avec ce plan
d'endettement nounou lyon les pieds et
les poings pour très longtemps
nos intérêts sont sacrifiés vous effacez
encore un peu de france
oui cet accord est le pire de notre
histoire le pire de l'histoire l'union
européenne pour la france monsieur le
premier ministre
comment comptez vous assumez un accord
qui mutile financièrement la france et
sacrifient les jeunes générations au nom
d'une vision idéologique
complètement dépassés
la parole est à monsieur clément bonne
secrétaire d'état chargé des affaires
européennes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs député monsieur le député
sébastien chenu j'en remercie de cette
question qui donne l'occasion de revenir
sur un accord puisque vous n'avez pas le
terme historique que je qualifierais
d'inédits la vérité c'est que vous
n'aimez pas l'europe et vous n'êtes pas
l'europe at elle réussi lorsque vous
n'aimez pas que la france soit forte en
europe
ce plan de relance il n'avait jamais été
obtenues et c'est un succès que nous
n'aurions célébrer collectivement parce
qu'il permettra d'apporter 750 milliards
d'euros à l'union européenne dans son
ensemble presque 400 milliards d'euros
de subventions budgétaires immédiates à
partir de la fin de cette année et vous
l'avez dit au moins 40 milliards d'euros
pour la france sans doute beaucoup plus
parce que nous parlons d'une partie
seulement du fonds de relance je tiens à
préciser aussi que préside la république
avec le soutien de l'ensemble je pense
sur ses bancs de vos positions à
négocier également un budget qui
préserve à s'attendre d'intérêt majeur
pour le pays
d'abord la politique agricole commune il
y a deux ans on parlait d'une veste 15
milliards d'euros en hausse de 15
milliards d'euros de la politique
agricole commune
nous sommes battus pendant deux ans avec
le miz agriculture et nous le savons
nous avons aujourd'hui des revenus qui
sont garantis sur sept ans pour les
agriculteurs français je pourrais
mentionner aussi les sommes
supplémentaires qui ont été obtenus pour
les régions d outre mer mais qui seront
aussi un succès et une force pour la
france ces dernières années la france
est le troisième bénéficiaire de ce plan
de relance
ce sera un argent qui sera disponible
immédiatement et il n'est pas vrai de
dire que cet argent augmentera les
impôts des français ni les entreprises
ni des citoyens vous pouvez le répéter
autant que vous le souhaitez monsieur le
député chenu ça n'est pas vrai parce que
nous avons obtenu la création de
ressources nouvelles pour des personnes
qui profitent de l'europe et qui ne
payent rien aujourd'hui les entreprises
du secteur du numérique les entreprises
polluantes qui exportent vers l'europe
et qui ne respecte pas nos standards
environnementaux
c'est un succès européen que nous
devrions célébrer ensemble parce qu'à la
fin ce sera 40 % du plan de relance
français
par l'union européenne ça n'a jamais été
fait alors essayons de porter cette
réussite collectivement merci beaucoup
et je veux dire pour cette première
réponse ma fierté d'être aujourd'hui
devant la représentation nationale
merci monsieur le ministre avant de
céder la parole à monsieur jean charles
taugourdeau je veux lui adresser au nom
de la représentation nationale nos
félicitations pour son élection de mer
de beaufort en anjou et lui souhaiter
tout le succès à la tête de la
municipalité
chers collègues vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président merci pour
vos félicitations monsieur le premier
ministre c'est avec une émotion sincère
que je prends la parole pour la dernière
fois dans notre hémicycle élu à quatre
reprises depuis 2002 je mesure au terme
de mon mandat combien la situation
économique de notre pays n'a
malheureusement guère évoluer je vous
entends dire et vous avez raison qu'il
est urgent et nécessaire de relancer
l'économie et la création de richesses
c'est ce que l'on entend mais ce n'est
pas ce qui se passe sur le terrain dans
ma circonscription 100% rural quand je
lis ce dimanche dans la presse que 47
agriculteurs du bassin de l'authion au
coeur de ma circonscription ont été
verbalisés pour le dépassement de leurs
quotas d'eau pendant la canicule de 2019
les bras m'en tombent déjà oublié
lakovic 19 avec des amendes de 800 à
7500 euros monsieur le premier ministre
bien sûr que la confiance n'exclut pas
le contrôle mais comment notre
administration
comment votre administration la police
de l'eau peut-elle continuer à
sanctionner sans appréciation de la
situation
monsieur le premier ministre je conçois
notre rôle de législateur comme un rôle
d'accompagnant et de facilitateur et non
comme le verbalisateurs d'un carcan
juridico-administratif illisible
incompréhensible injuste parfois jusqu'à
stupide mais toujours prêt à sanctionner
j'ai toujours plaidé pour une formation
du législateur parce que la loi est
écrite par les juristes
alors que le législateur parle comme
tout le monde
mais les deux langages ne se comprennent
pas le même au tribunal et d'un sens au
café du village
il est de l'autre monsieur le premier
ministre je vous invite
venez chez moi dans ma circonscription a
constaté malheureusement la gravité de
l'accident subi par la ruralité pour un
fait divers grave tout le monde se
déplace pour l'accident de 47
agriculteurs j'aimerais que vous vous
déplaciez mon adresse est facile celle à
49,3 monsieur le premier ministre
merci chers collègues séparant le
terrain d'à me barbara pompili ministre
de la transition écologique
merci merci monsieur le président
monsieur débuté tout d'abord toutes mes
félicitations pour votre élection et
pour votre engagement que nous
connaissons ici et qui a été constant
sur la question de la police de l'eau et
du monde agricole
je suis je suis très très très attaché
au fait que les liens puisse être renoué
nous avons besoin de ce travail ensemble
de mettre tous les acteurs autour de la
table sur des territoires pour qu'on
puisse avancer sur cette question de
l'eau qui est une question essentielle
pour notre avenir commun nous allons
devoir partager l'eau nous avons des
lieux et vous le savez particulièrement
sur votre territoire où il y a
malheureusement des sécheresses des
tensions sur l'utilisation de l'eau et
il faut que tout le monde puisse
l'utiliser
la police de l'ol doit être là pour
aider les agriculteurs pour les informer
pour les soutenir
mais elle ne peut pas le faire tout seul
donc on a un certain nombre de mesures
qui sont aujourd'hui mises en place avec
les agences de l'eau pour aider les
agriculteurs à s'équiper avec aussi les
différents contrats que nous allons
mettre en place et qui sont en train de
se mettre en place sur les territoires
et nous avons aussi des parlementaires
qui ont fait un rapport qui est sorti
très récemment et je salue frédéric
tufnell et loïc prud'hommes qui ont fait
un rapport sur la gestion des conflits
de l'eau qui propose un certain nombre
de solutions et que nous allons regarder
de très près pour pouvoir justement
faire en sorte que tout cela se passe
mieux
les agriculteurs ont leur part à faire
aussi ils doivent travailler sur comment
mieux économiser l'eau mais encore une
fois nous
rien seuls nous ne ferons rien les a
opposés aux autres nous réussirons
ensemble sur ce défi qui est un défi
très important nous voyons aujourd'hui
aussi avec les incendies la question de
l'eau c'est notre avenir à tous et vous
pouvez compter sur le gouvernement pour
nous aider tous à y arriver
merci merci madame la ministre
la parole est à mme adama pardon je
voulais juste dire monsieur le président
que je recevrai madame la ministre
grand plaisir dans ma commune de
beaufort en anjou et je vous montrerai
l'environnement agricole merci monsieur
le député d'amal bangai o je vous
remercie monsieur le président monsieur
le premier ministre mes chers collègues
l'acte de procréation et l'acte de
liberté par excellence la liberté entre
toutes les libertés la liberté la plus
fondamentale la plus intime de nos
libertés et personne personne n'a jamais
pu obliger une femme a donné la vie
quand allait décider de ne pas le faire
c'est ainsi que gisèle halimi concluait
sa célèbre le plaidoirie lors du procès
de bobigny une immense féministes nous a
quittés aujourd'hui et nous savons ce
que nous lui devons
à l'heure où le droit à l'avortement est
mis en danger aux quatre coins du monde
nous lui devons de poursuivre ce combat
ne lutter contre toutes les formes
d'obscurantisme quel qu'il soit de
préserver la plus intime de nos libertés
nous lui devons ne jamais nous résigner
plus de quarante ans après le vote de la
loi veil dans cet hémicycle le droit à
l'avortement et mise en danger
il est mise en danger par le manque
d'ambition concrète de politique
publique en matière d'éducation à la
sexualité par les nombreuses fermetures
d'établissements spécialisés dans l'eee
vg qui créent de larges disparités entre
les territoires par la cause de
conscience spécifique ali viger qui
consacre l'avortement comme un acte à
part par mes chers collègues
chacun de ces obstacles peut être levé
par une adaptation à la marge de notre
droit car nous considérons qu'une
liberté aussi fondamental que le droit à
l'avortement doit le pouvoir dépasser
les clivages politiques
nous avons déposé le 16 juillet dernier
une proposition de loi transpartisane
visant à améliorer l'effectivité du
droit à l'avortement
monsieur le ministre ma question est
simple partagez-vous notre constat sur
l'effectivité du droit à l'avortement et
soutiendrait vous cette proposition de
loi pour que la france s'impose comme
l'un des pays les plus progressistes en
la matière je vous remercie
ta parole de monsieur olivier véran
ministre des solidarités et de la santé
madame la députée elle bangai o vous
parlez de de gisèle gisèle halimi
mondiaux la vie de cette femme toute sa
vie elle a été bousculée par tous elle
est à l'est pour avoir voulu bousculer
nos consciences
toute sa vie elle a pris des risques
toute sa vie elle a su anticiper avec
ferveur avec conviction avec talent tous
les grands débats que la société allait
connaître et quelle est la traversée en
1972 elle se bat pour que liv et gène
soit plus reconnu comme un crime
il aura fallu deux ans pour que le
parlement dans les conditions qu'on
connaît aujourd'hui aille dans ce sens
en 1978 elle s'est battue pour que le
viol soit reconnu comme un crime
là encore il aura fallu attendre deux
ans imaginez l'année ma naissance pour
qu'on considère que le viol était un
crime il est des combats qui sont menées
par des femmes parfois par des hommes
mais souvent par des femmes qui sont des
combats qui sont difficiles pour celles
et ceux qui le mène au moment où il la
mène et c'est toujours très intéressant
et parfois même émouvant de constater
que 10 ans 20 ans 30 ans 40 ans après
finalement ces combats mesdames et
messieurs les députés finissent par
faire consensus
je crois que on peut ressortir tous les
écrits qu'elle avait publié en soixante
douze sur l'île et j'ai quand on entend
parfois certains débats qui peuvent
encore émaillé notre société quand on
regarde certaines campagnes honteuses de
publicité dans le métro encore en
janvier 2020
les combats ne sont jamais gagné
définitivement il nous faut les porter
avec conviction on peut compter sur des
grandes femmes comme 6l halimi on peut
aussi compter sur la ferveur d'un
parlement qui croient aux avancées
sociales nous avons ensuite sociétal
madame la députée ministre des
solidarités la santé et membre de ce
gouvernement je défendrai bec et ongles
en toutes circonstances tous les droits
des femmes
évidemment le droit d'avorter le droit
pour les femmes
de disposer pleinement de leur corps
nous devons travailler ensemble à ces
questions encore et encore ça ne sera
jamais à parler au passé
merci monsieur le ministre la parole à
madame elsa faucillon à madame guillaume
dément je vous remercie j'ai bien
entendu votre engagement complet pour le
droit des femmes et votre soutien plein
et entier à tous qu'il faudra garantir
l'effectivité droit avortement je
voudrais rappeler l'ampleur du phénomène
ces packs on le dit parfois que c'est
injuste un phénomène lié aux qu'ovide
non chaque année 3000 à 5000 femmes
partent avorter à l'étranger
le hce nous informait d en 2013 la
fermeture de plus de 130 centres de
planification et ivg est aujourd'hui
quand il s'en veut avorter elle avorte
trois points de suspension
merci cholet la parole est à madame
alsace
merci monsieur le président depuis plus
de six ans une répression systématique
s'abat sur toutes les voix critiques en
egypte arrestations arbitraires
détention provisoire prolongée torture
disparitions forcées couverte par la
mise en place d'un système de justice
parallèle il y a un an le militant et
défenseur des droits rami saâd égyptiens
et palestiniens était appréhendé à son
domicile en egypte puis emprisonné sa
femme française céline lebrun était
présente elle a été privée l'assistance
consulaire avant d'être expulsé en
france au mépris de l'article 36 de la
convention de vienne depuis la détention
de rami sat a été renouvelé dix-sept
fois aucune sans aucune accusation
formelle
les charges sont uniquement liés à son
exercice pacifique du droit à la liberté
d'expression
ses conditions de détention sont
inquiétantes en plein qu'ovide rami
partage sa cellule de 25 mètres carrés
avec 17 personnes depuis 2018 la france
a annoncé faire de la protection des
défenseurs des droits humains un axe
prioritaire de sa diplomatie
engagement réitéré lors de sa
candidature à la présidence du conseil
des droits humains de l'onu
dans le même temps le montant des
livraisons d'armes
de la france en 2010 9 représente plus
d'un milliard d'euros de matériel de
guerre livrée sans livrer sans compter
les véhicules blindés de combat utilisés
dans le cadre de la répression
ces dernières années la diplomatie
française à privilégier un dialogue
privé sur les droits humains
cette approche a largement échoué le
silence de ses alliés s'avèrent en
réalité la meilleure arme des autorités
égyptiennes ne croyez vous pas qu'une
dénonciation publique d'un allié aussi
important que la france pour l'egypte
serait un premier pas pour enrayer cette
spirale
nous savons que le cas de rami sade est
suivi par le ministère au plus haut
niveau
aussi quelles initiatives diplomatiques
seront prises à partir de maintenant et
à quel niveau pour assister la citoyenne
française céline lebrun claque c'était
la libération de ran la parole de
monsieur jean yves le drian ministre de
l'europe et des affaires étrangères et
madame madame la députée et ça fout sion
vous avez rappelé que la france a un
partenariat important avec l'egypte
c'est un partenariat sur les questions
économiques c'est un partenariat sur les
questions culturelles
c'est un partenariat contre le
terrorisme c'est aussi un partenariat
une fois ne faut pas l'oublier de
d'action en commun pour éviter
l'annexion de la cisjordanie par les
autorités israéliennes
mais ce partenariat la madame la députée
ne signifie pas un blanc-seing sur la
question des droits de l'homme nous y
sommes extrêmement attentifs et nous
considérons une le disons haut à aux
autorités égyptiennes que la vitalité de
la société civile égyptienne est le
meilleur rempart contre le terrorisme et
la radicalisation et dans ce cadre là
nous insistons notamment sur la question
des arrestations de défenseurs des
droits de l'homme sur la question du
droit à un procès équitable pour chacun
et surtout en ce moment sur les
conditions de détention dans les prisons
égyptiennes
puisque vous le savez vous l'avez
d'ailleurs dit les détenus font partie
des populations les plus exposées
lakovic 19 les autorités égyptiennes
sous la pression ont déjà commencé à
procéder à un certain nombre de
libérations de détenus
nous les invitons à poursuivre
publiquement nous les invitons
aujourd'hui à poursuivre et à élargir
cette démarche en particulier de
respecter l'engagement et l'appel du
secrétaire général des nations unies à
cet égard et pour revenir à l'attention
toute particulière que vous avez
évoquées à l'égard de monsieur sastre et
de madame céline lebrun zad nous sommes
vous le savez en lien très étroit et
très régulier avec madame céline lebrun
et nous avons à de nombreuses reprises
de manière privée mais aussi de manière
publique jeudi ici publiquement demandé
à ce que les conditions de détention de
monsieur zaz soit améliorée et qu'il
aide les conditions de relations entre
madame lebrun et son mari puisse être
revu pour lui permettre d'avoir une
relation proche avec lui-même
je répète cela régulièrement aux
autorités égyptiennes et je suis de près
ce dossier
merci monsieur le ministre la parole à
michel victory
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre de l'éducation nationale comme
nous tous vous avez pu constater
j'imagine les conséquences de la crise
sanitaire sur les enfants et les
adolescents de notre pays aggravation
des inégalités déjà présentes se sont
encore une fois les élèves des milieux
les plus défavorisés qui ont abandonné
leur scolarité et que l'institution
malgré tout la compétence et la bonne
volonté des équipes enseignantes n'a pu
retrouver
nous ignorons dans quelles conditions se
fera la prochaine rentrée
mais nous sommes certains qu'il faut
davantage d'adultes dans les
établissements scolaires pour rectifier
cette trajectoire délétère les a eu des
assistants d'éducation catégorique créé
en 2003 ont remplacé les maîtres
d'internât et d'externat dans les
collèges et les lycées ils sont recrutés
depuis pour assurer les fonctions de
soutien et d'éducation aux côtés des
enseignants tandis que leur nombre a
baissé de 2% entre 2008 et 2018 la
population scolaire elle a augmenté de
2% à l'évidence les horaires de ces
emplois ne correspondent pas à la
réalité des besoins des étudiants 70 %
des abonnés ne se destine pas aux
carrières de l'enseignement et la
majorité ne sont pas des étudiants
rendant l'argument de la
préprofessionnalisation vous aviez mise
en avant lors de
la loi de l'école de la confiance plus
que discutable les chefs d'établissement
qui leur vient de recruter ces
personnels le disent ils ont besoin de
ces personnels de vie scolaire pour
répondre aux enjeux d'intégration et de
réussite que notre système leur doit or
ces personnels sont recrutés sous un
statut totalement précaire sur une durée
de trois ans renouvelable dans la limite
de six ans pour 39 heures hebdomadaires
à intégrer dans des équipes éducatives
dans une relation constructive avec les
élèves
ils ont pendant la crise contribuer à
garder un contact avec les plus fragiles
pourtant ccad n'ont toujours pas obtenu
un véritable statut conforme à leurs
engagements ils sont remerciés à bhl à
tout moment ont de grandes difficultés à
faire valises valider les acquis de leur
expérience
il reste à ce jour la seule catégorie de
l'éducation des personnels en avoir
obtenu la possibilité d'une cdi isation
et ne bénéficie pas de la prime serait
plus cette situation ne peut perdurer
mais c'est le maire cible le député il
faut répondre à cette question par la
parole de monsieur jean michel blanquer
ministre de l'éducation nationale et de
la jeunesse
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés
la députée michèle victory vous avez
raison de souligner l'importance des
assistants d'éducation
ils sont absolument essentiel dans le
système éducatif et on le voit dans
chaque établissement il ya toujours un
grand besoin d'assistants d'éducation
parce que c'est eux qui assurent un
grand nombre de missions notamment pour
la pour la vie scolaire
le point de divergence que j'aurai avec
vous c'est quand vous critiquez le
principe du prérecrutement votre
argument est un peu étonnant puisque
vous dites que parce que un bon nombre
d'assistants d'éducation ne seront pas
professeur il n'est pas bon de
considérer qu'un certain nombre d'entre
eux doivent être envisagées comme
prérecruter ce que nous avons fait au
travers de la loi pour l'école de la
confiance bien sûr ce point je suis en
profond désaccord avec vous parce que
nous avons besoin de renouer avec ce qui
a été une grande tradition de la
république justement qui était d'avoir
des jeunes souvent jeunes étudiants qui
se destinent à être professeur et qui ne
vivent pas cette mission comme étant
quelque chose qui les gêne pour leurs
études mais au contraire comme quelque
chose qui leur permet d'avoir à la fois
une rémunération et même une préparation
pour le métier de professeur
au moment où nous faisons flèche de tout
bois pour redonner de l'attractivité au
métier de professeur
ce pré recrutement qui a commencé depuis
septembre 2019 est au contraire une
grande piste que nous allons renforcer à
l'occasion de la prochaine rentrée
alors vous me demandez si ses assistants
d'éducation doivent être renforcées oui
ils doivent l'être d'abord parce qu'il y
aura plus de pré recrutement dès la
prochaine rentrée
et puis ensuite parce que nous serons
toujours plus attentifs au suivi
qualitatif de ses assistants d'éducation
est en effet ils vont jouer un grand
rôle à la rentrée scolaire parce que
c'est en partie sur eux que nous
comptons pour le renforcement de
l'opération de voir fait de voir fait
depuis trois ans est un très grand
succès pour aider les élèves en
difficulté il y aura plus d'heures de
devoir faire la rentrée au collège
et puis bien entendu il y aura les
heures supplémentaires elle ne concerne
pas les assistants d'éducation elle
concerne les professeurs et c'est ainsi
que à la fois par les assistants
d'éducation et par les professeurs nous
allons avoir de l'aide personnalisée
renforcée pour nos élèves à la rentrée
merci monsieur le ministre
la parole est à madame me valérie 6
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
monsieur le premier ministre
environ 750 mille jeunes vont entrer sur
le marché du travail en septembre
prochain
l'avenir de nos jeunes et donc entre nos
mains
notre pays traverse une crise sanitaire
inédite aujourd'hui nous nous préparons
à une crise économique de grande ampleur
madame la ministre du travail lisa bête
borne à déclarer
l'objectif c'est aucun jeunes sans
solution à la rentrée monsieur le
premier ministre vous avez alors
présenté le 23 juillet dernier un plan
jeunes de 6 5 milliards d'euros sur deux
ans afin de lutter contre le chômage des
jeunes
sachez que nous saluons ce plan un jeune
une solution et que nous serons
vigilants quant à sa mise en oeuvre
en effet monsieur le premier ministre
les services de pôle emploi les missions
locales s'attendent à une recrudescence
des inscriptions chez les 16 25 ans
d'ici la fin de l'année afin d'aider ces
structures d'accompagnement qui
accueille oriente nos jeunes vers un
emploi ou une formation
quels moyens humains et financiers allez
vous mettre en place afin qu'ils
puissent honorer les honorait les
objectifs fixés le temps est compté
jusqu'au 1er janvier 2021 date butoir
pour l'octroi des aides promises par le
gouvernement dans la loi de finances
rectificatif fr3 la prime exceptionnelle
al embauche des apprentis et versées
sans condition pour les entreprises de
moins de 250 salariés
pour les autres son octroi est
conditionnée à un objectif de 5 %
d'apprentis dans l'effectif total de
l'entreprise
notre souhait est la relance de
l'apprentissage en france peu importe la
taille de l'entreprise le gouvernement
serait t'il favorable à la suppression
de cette condition afin de soutenir tous
les apprentis l'avenir de nos jeunes
c'est l'avenir de notre pays ne les
décevrons pas merci merci chers
collègues la parole à madame sarah est
la hérie secrétaire d'état chargée de la
jeunesse et de l'engagement
[Musique]
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les députés madame la députée valérie 6
tu sais j'ai une certaine émotion
évidemment à répondre à cette première
question pour plusieurs raisons la
première c'est que la semaine dernière
j'ai été à vos côtés sur surface sur nos
bancs sur vauban et ça ça donne une
certaine émotion d'aller de l'autre côté
une double émotion puisque j'aurai la
responsabilité auprès de jean michel
blanquer air de porter la question de la
jeunesse et de l'engagement
et vous l'avez dit dans vos propos c'est
essentiel c'est essentiel d'autant plus
qu'aujourd'hui ils sortent d'une crise
d'une crise majeure
et pour répondre vraiment à votre à
votre question je pense qu'il est
nécessaire de rappeler que ce blanc ce
plan pour la jeunesse de 6,5 milliards
d'euros est un acte fort un hacker
montrer que vous savez ça lui est
d'ailleurs et qui est composée de
différentes manières la première d'entre
elles c'est évidemment le la
compensation jusqu'à 4000 euros pour un
recrutement d'un jeune de moins de 25
ans et c'est essentiel jusqu'à 2 smic
pour permettre également aux jeunes
diplômés d'y accéder il y a un là
l'augmentation du nombre de missions de
service civique avec 100 milles
supplémentaires mais également vous avez
vous avez apporté et souligné
l'importance de l'apprentissage et de
l'alternance avec le fait avec
l'augmentation de 200 euros
supplémentaires pour les moins de 16 ans
et sansan pour les 18 à 25 ans c'est
aussi un effort considérable pour
accompagner notre jeunesse et les dix
autres jeunesse elle est différente il
ya celles qui cherchent du travail celle
qui est en étude celle qui a besoin
d'une recherche d'une mission je pense
qu'il faut accompagner toute notre
jeunesse
quel que soit son chemin et nos jeunesse
elles sont différentes en fonction au
territoire également elles n'ont pas les
mêmes chances qu'elle soit en
territoires ruraux avec des problèmes de
mobilité péri urbain ou en ultra urbain
ou encore en quartiers politique de la
ville
je crois que notre jeunesse il faut
répondre à chacune d'entre elles la
compagnie pour qu'elle soit plus
ambitieux et je me rends compte que je
suis encore beaucoup trop longue mais
bon je pense que le gouvernement est et
sera aux côtés de notre jeunesse dans
pour toute notre jeunesse je vous
remercie
si madame la ministre la parole est à
madame marianne dubois
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
et j'y associe mes collègues olivier
marleix que c'est julien dive mais
j'aurais pu en citer beaucoup d'autres
nous assistons depuis plusieurs mois à
la mise à mort de toute une filière
celle de l'industrie betteravière
française
une mise à mort sciemment organisée par
les gouvernements successifs de votre
majorité
la cause la jaunisse virale introduite
par un puceron qui touchent 100 % des
plantations dans notre région centre val
de loire
le remède l'enrobage des semences ans et
n'est ni que vous avez interdit pour
sauver leur campagne certains
exploitants ont été jusqu'à porter six
traitements d'insecticides sans aucun
résultat
un non sens environnemental et
économique dans notre région ce sont
trente et un mille hectares 1700
exploitation maintenant 3 sucreries
depuis la fermeture récente de celle de
toury 5000 emplois directs et indirects
que vous sacrifier sans compter la perte
immédiate 2000 euros par hectare dès
l'année prochaine nous allons assister à
l'abandon de milliers d'hectares de
culture betteravière faute de solution
technique puis les fermetures de
sucreries s'enchaîneront faute de
disposer de matière première en quantité
suffisante pour atteindre leur
rentabilité
pourtant le ministre de l'agriculture
multiplie les déplacements et constate
le désastre mais les belles photos les
belles paroles les beaux articles ne
sauveront pas nos agriculteurs
n'empêcheront pas la fermeture de nos
usines
il ne protégeront pas davantage nos
concitoyens de futurs importations
massives de sucre produit dans des
conditions sanitaires et
environnementales très éloignées de
celles que vous nous imposez monsieur le
ministre
allez-vous avoir le courage et
l'honnêteté de dire nos agriculteurs et
industriels que vous les abandonnés ou
contraire allez vous avoir le courage de
mettre en pratique les paroles
présidentielles en permettant l'enrobage
protecteur des semis de betteraves dès
la tante d'une alternative technique
viable disent merci
la parole est à monsieur julien de
normandie ministre de l'agriculture et
de l'alimentation
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les députés madame
la députée marianne dubois pour éclairer
le débat il se passe une catastrophe en
ce moment dans les champs de betteraves
qu'est ce que c'est que cette
catastrophe
c'est un puceron vert qui vient injecter
un virus qui s'appelle le virus de la
jaunisse et qui vient faire en sorte
qu'il n'y a plus de photosynthèse et
donc les bulbes de béterette n'arrive
plus à grossir et c'est toute une
filière qui est effectivement menacée et
vous savez madame la députée on se
retrouve sur un point un point très fort
c'est qu'il faut trouver une solution et
je peux vous dire que dire à moi que je
vais m'amuser dans les champs pour faire
des photos pour toutes celles et ceux
qui me connaissent c'est quand même un
peu fort de café
ça fait trois semaines que je travaille
d'arrache-pied pour essayer de trouver
une solution et on va se parler
franchement madame la députée du bois
qu'est ce qui se passe
le gouvernement actuel qu'est ce qu'il
est en train de faire il est en train de
mettre en application une loi votée en
2016 la réalité elle est là il ya quand
même un respect par rapport à un pouvoir
législatif que vous représentez elle et
elle l est où madame la députée la
proposition de loi que vous auriez pu
déposer depuis quatre ans pour dire aux
français on veut revenir sur les
néonicotinoïdes elle est là la réalité
donc chacun doit assumer ses
responsabilités et moi je peux vous dire
une chose madame la députée ce secteur
de la betterave que je respecte ce
secteur de la betterave qui est un
événement de souveraineté alimentaire
jamais jamais jamais je ne
l'abandonnerai mais il ya un point que
le pouvoir exécutif ne peut pas faire
c'est changer la loi
si ça n'est pas le pouvoir législatif
qui le fait et donc aujourd'hui on a un
double choix on change la loi où on met
une filière avec énormément de soutien
financier ce sur quoi nous travaillons
avec le premier ministre mais chacun
doit assumer ses responsabilités et moi
je prends un engagement devant toute la
filière c'est de travailler autant qu'il
faudra pour trouver des solutions parce
que jamais je n'abandonnerai cette
filière mais nos poliment poli
pas de polémique là-dessus mais en
revanche au travail et c'est ce que je
fais c'est pas des photos que chantera
[Musique]
merci monsieur élevé
la parole est à monsieur cédric roussel
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre des
sports madame la ministre monsieur le
premier ministre lors de sa déclaration
de politique générale ici dans cet
hémicycle a cité le sport à plusieurs
reprises ce qui dans cet exercice est
assez rare et mérite d'être souligné
vous le savez lors de la crise sanitaire
le mouvement sportif a scrupuleusement
respecté les consignes gouvernementales
il a placé la santé des français au
dessus de tout il s'est également
distingué sur notre territoire en
concourant à la mobilisation citoyenne
pour soutenir celles et ceux qui étaient
en première ligne face à l'épidémie
je pense notamment dans mon département
des alpes-maritimes aux actions de
solidarité menées par l'ogcnice et
l'ensemble des acteurs sportifs locaux
pour venir en aide aux personnels
soignants et aux plus précaires pendant
le confinement comme tous les secteurs
le sport a consenti des sacrifices
majeurs
on estime ses pertes à plus de 20
milliards d'euros
aujourd'hui le monde du sport qui
représente 450 mille emplois s'inquiète
et à temps les mesures concrètes
je ne voudrais pas que la seule reprise
du championnat de football professionnel
soit l'arbre qui cache la forêt les
autres disciplines dont le modèle
économique n'est pas basée sur les
droits télé font face à des difficultés
fondamentales
je pense aussi aux trois cent soixante
mille clubs et associations sportives
amateurs qui anime le territoire et sont
frappés par la crise répondant à l'appel
du premier ministre et aux attentes du
monde sportif
nous avons mis la semaine dernière au
gouvernement avec mon collègue françois
cormier bulli gion et 72 députés de la
majorité un plan comportant 50 mesures
pour relancer le sport français
un plan de choc de confiance pour les
pratiquants également pour les acteurs
de la filière pour envisager des
investissements pour envisager un avenir
madame la ministre le sport a rythmé la
vie de beaucoup de nos concitoyens lors
du confinement
nous ne souhaitons pas qu'il soit le
grand oublié à son issue à 80 de nos
jeux olympiques le sport et sa filière
de compétence reconnue à travers le
monde doivent occuper une place
essentielle au simple maintenant je ne
sais que le député l'impossible pouvez
vous nous préciser l'ambitieux doivent
signer à nu ministre délégué chargé des
sports avait dit mme monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
députés monsieur le député roussel je
salue et je vous remercie et je partage
totalement votre engagement
monsieur roussel celui du député cormier
bullygeois ainsi que de tout le groupe
l'arrêt mais de la majorité aux côtés du
monde sportif les propositions vous avez
fait
soyez en sûr nourrissent déjà le plan du
relance du sport auquel je suis très
attaché j'y suis attaché parce que le
monde du sport a été particulièrement
impacté par la crise du fait de l'arrêt
total des activités des structures de la
disparition des écrans et des stades
toutes compétitions sportives et
événementielles et c'est vrai que
lorsqu'on sait qu'un une annulation d'un
match de football c'est déjà 5 millions
d'euros de pertes pour l'organisateur on
arrive facilement 20 milliards d'euros
que vous avez évoquées pour le manque à
gagner pour le monde sportif
j'y suis attaché à ce plan de relance du
sport parce que je crois intimement
qu'au delà de l'épanouissement personnel
de chacun pour lequel les éducateurs
sportifs les associations les structures
privées les salles de sport ont
largement contribué pendant le
confinement avec le sport à la maison
le programme de sport en ligne le sport
est crucial pour l'éducation de nos
enfants d'abord nous allons y travailler
avec jean michel blanquer pour la santé
de nos concitoyens nous allons y
travailler avec bree brigitte
bourguignon avec olivier ferrand mais
aussi pour participer à la transition
écologique
compte tenu du nombre d'équipements
sportifs à rénover dans un objectif d'
impact carbone réduit il ya aussi le
lien social sur nos territoires qui est
essentiel et auquel nos associations
sportives contribuer nous avons donné
des le déconfinement la possibilité aux
associations sportives de se positionner
sur tous les dispositifs financés par
l'état des dispositifs d aide à la
trésorerie
au total 3 milliards d'euros qui
vont aller jusqu'à fin septembre soutien
de l'activité partielle dans le domaine
du sport des dispositifs d aide à la
transformation des 200 millions d'euros
débloqués sur vacances apprenantes
sachez que 60% des structures qui ont
contribué sont des structures sportives
mais aussi un plan daide pour l'emploi
plus de 2500 emplois dans le domaine du
sport financés par l' agence nationale
si madame ligue 1 s'il atteint les
curieux vincent rolland merci monsieur
le président ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le premier ministre
le transport décarbonée nous sommes pour
mais voilà entre les annonces du
président de la république sur le
développement du train de nuit ou celle
du gouvernement sur le développement du
rail
il y à un gouffre avec la réalité
actuelle
j'en veux pour preuve la suppression du
train de nuit entre paris et bourse à
maurice il y a déjà plusieurs années
malgré de nombreuses interventions pour
sa réintroduction
celles ci sont à ce jour restée lettre
morte
pourtant partout en europe ce mode de
transport se développe désormais encore
dernièrement eurostar détenue à 55% par
la sncf a annoncé sans concertation
préalable
la suppression de la ligne londres les
alpes qui transportent chaque saison
hivernale trente mille britanniques vers
les stations de ski
ceux ci vont ils devoir privilégier
l'avion ou la voiture vous en
conviendrez
pour utiliser les transports décarbonée
il faut d'abord qu'il existe une offre
aussi monsieur le premier ministre
afin de concilier préservation de
l'environnement et les activités
économiques et touristiques
je vous demande quelles mesures
concrètes j'ai bien dit concrètes vous
comptez engagé pour réintroduire les
trains de nuit en général et la ligne
notamment bourg-saint-maurice paris l
eurostar long
dans les alpes je vous remercie merci
monsieur le député la parole tavana
barbara pompili ministre chargé de la
transition écologique
merci monsieur monsieur le président
monsieur le député vous savez
l'engagement que je porte et que porte
le gouvernement sur cette question de la
régénération du ferroviaire et je suis
je suis ravi de voir que vous souhaitez
également vous impliquer nous avons déjà
voté dans la loi mobilité puisque nous
ne commençons pas aujourd'hui nous avons
déjà voté dans la loi mobilité un
certain nombre de mesures qui avaient
été prises notamment parce qu'il y avait
eu un gros travail notamment par le
conseil d'orientation des
infrastructures pour identifier quelles
sont les priorités parce que pendant des
années nous avons laissé à vau l'eau
le ferroviaire nous n'avons pas
suffisamment entretenu et dit nous avons
pas vrai nous n'avons pas ils
réutilisent est suffisamment de matériel
résultat nous avons du retard à
rattraper ce retard ça ne se rattrape
pas sans méthode donc la méthode elle a
été élaborée dans la loi sur les
mobilités et aujourd'hui ce que nous y
apportons ce sont des moyens puisque
grâce au programme au plan de relance
nous allons nous avons les derniers
arbitrages pour l'instant donc je ne
vais pas vous donner des chiffres exacts
ils vous seront évidemment donné au
moment où le plan de relance sera
présente et c'est à dire en fin août
vous aurez des investissements massifs
sur le ferroviaire pour que pour que
enfin les lignes puissent être remise à
niveau pour que nous ayons des meilleurs
matériels parce qu'il faut aussi si vous
voulez des trains de nuit avoir des
matériels de qualité
monsieur le député nous avons aussi vous
le savez hier lors du conseil de défense
écologique annoncé un certain nombre de
mesures sur le fret ferroviaire que le
premier ministre a annoncé hier après
midi
ces différentes mesures font l'objet
d'un paquet puisque ce sont des mesures
qui s'étale dans le temps mais je peux
vous dire monsieur le député que si vous
en voulez du train vous allez en avoir
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président je prends
mohlala ministre et je me félicite que
des crédits seront affectés pour les
trains de nuit mais dans la loi l'homme
s'était 30 millions d'euros et avec 30
millions d'euros franchement ne fait pas
grand solo mais nous suivrons cela avec
beaucoup d'intérêt je vous remercie
si j'ai un collègue la parole et à
monsieur sylvain waserman je remercie
monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à un atelier limaces
secrétaire d'état à l'enseignement
prioritaire madame la ministre je dois
d'abord très sincèrement vous féliciter
pour votre nomination et vous souhaiter
une pleine réussite dans cette mission
qui est une mission est une mission
essentielle est essentielle pour notre
république est essentielle pour nos
quartiers prioritaires essentiel pour ma
ville de strasbourg kehl je suis élu
ma question est la suivante en début de
mandat nous avons mis en oeuvre un
dispositif qui était une promesse du
président de la république qui est le
dispositif des 12 enfants par classe le
ministre jean michel blanquer étaient
venus d'ailleurs dans ma circonscription
à la meinau pour voir la façon dont ce
dispositif était mis en oeuvre tous les
ans depuis lors je dialogue avec les
enseignants de la meinau et du neuf pour
avoir le ressenti leur retour
d'expérience sur cette mesure ce qu'il
me dise
et j'imagine que beaucoup d'entre nous
ont le même ressenti ce qu'il me dit
c'est que avant ce dispositif 4 à 5
enfants par classe de cp n'était pas
rentré dans la lecture à la sortie du cp
et qu'aujourd'hui il y en a un au
maximum ça signifie que leur ressenti
c'est que dans chacun des quartiers de
notre ville de strasbourg des quartiers
prioritaires 4 3 à 4 enfants entre
guillemets sortent d'une espèce de
déterminisme social et ont toutes leurs
chances de réussite de leur parcours
scolaire
ma question madame la ministre c'est que
on a beaucoup de ressentis terrain et
d'expérience mais qu'il faut maintenant
passer à une évaluation stricte de ces
dispositifs
alors madame la ministre
serez-vous la ministre d'une évaluation
rigoureuse et stricte de ces dispositifs
je pense également à celui des des sites
et éducatives auxquelles je crois
vraiment ce qui fédère tous les acteurs
de terrain serez-vous la ministre de
l'évaluation de ces dispositifs pour
prouver pour prouver que l'éducation
prioritaire n'est pas une dépense mais
que c'est bien un investissement
d'avenir
je remercie sherco l'oeil secrétaire
d'état chargé de l'éducation prioritaire
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés
monsieur le député sylvain waserman jeu
tout d'abord vous remercier pour vos
voeux et vous dire combien cette mission
celle de l'éducation prioritaire est
essentiel et je suis déterminé à oeuvrer
sans relâche aux côtés de jean michel
blanquer pour la réussite scolaire de
tous nos élèves de tous nos enfants
vous m'interrogez spécifiquement sur la
mise en place du dédoublement des
classes dans les réseaux d'éducation
prioritaire promesse du président de la
république
cette mesure a fait ses preuves les
chiffres que vous évoquez venant de
votre circonscription sont en effet
éloquents et démontre que nous pouvons
de manière très concrète améliorer la
situation de nos enfants cette
évaluation a déjà été réalisé avec de
premiers résultats très positifs ce qui
a d'ailleurs conduit à élargir le
dispositif aux classes de grande section
ces résultats d'ailleurs sont conformes
aux études françaises et internationales
qui démontre le lien moins d'enfants
dans les classes et meilleures seront
leurs résultats les objectifs poursuivis
sont atteints dans les classes
concernées qu'il s'agisse de
l'amélioration du climat scolaire dans
les classes des conditions de travail
des professeurs de la personnalisation
accrue des pratiques professionnelles et
des formations et également de l'or de
l'accompagnement des professeurs je suis
donc pleinement en accord avec vous
l'évaluation des politiques publiques
est absolument essentiel afin de
s'assurer au delà des annonces que les
mesures ambitieuses
porté par le gouvernement soit
effectivement déployé sur l'ensemble de
notre territoire de manière efficace
concernant l'évaluation spécifique des
sites et éducative
un comité national d'orientation et
d'évaluation présidée par la députée
sylvie charrière est chargé du suivi et
de l'évaluation du programme vous pouvez
compter sur moi monsieur le député pour
réveiller tout particulièrement et pour
chaque réforme engagée devrait sur le
terrain dans tous nos territoires pour
fédérer les nausées les énergies parce
qu'il s'agit de la condition essentielle
de réussite de nos élèves et surtout de
notre réussite collective et je vous
remercie merci morice
la parole est à monsieur jacques cattin
[Applaudissements]
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'agriculture met ses
ministres lors de votre intervention la
semaine dernière vous aviez évoqué que
l'accord européen allait permettre de
sauvegarder la politique agricole
commune la pac il notamment son volet
environnemental
il est en effet essentiel de maintenir
entre autres votre responsabilité
financière en faveur de l'agriculture de
montagne dont le renouvellement des
contrats mlc pour les cinq prochaines
années comme cela était d'ailleurs le
cas jusqu'à présent
la région grand est a été
particulièrement bon élève sur le
territoire alsacien dans la gestion des
fonds feader 2014 2020 est dédié aux
projets agro environnementales et
climatiques pour une montagne vivante la
région a d'ores et déjà annoncé le
renouvellement de son engagement pour
les cinq prochaines années nous élus
agriculteurs de montagne ne comprenons
pas des tergiversations de l'état qui ne
souhaite s'engager que sur un an pour
80% des quinze mille hectares concernés
la mise en route des pratiques
agroécologiques adapté à la préservation
de la biodiversité aussi bien en zone
natura 2000 quand deux ans
or relève d'une stratégie de territoire
et d'une adhésion massive des
exploitations avec une vision à moyen et
long terme
monsieur le ministre alors que monsieur
le premier ministre jean castex que je
salue souhaitent des compacts et cet
état trop uniformiser trop centralisée
trop jacobins et que l'occasion vous est
donnée sur ce dossier mais sioniste de
l'agriculture allez-vous l'aider à y
parvenir en faisant confiance à nos
territoires merci merci
la parole est à monsieur julien de
normandie ministère de l'agriculture de
l'alimentation
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les députés merci
monsieur le député pour votre excellente
question sans paraphraser quiconque
très clairement il faut il faut encore
plus demain qu'aujourd'hui partir des
territoires pour développer les projets
agroécologiques je vous rejoins deux
cent mille pour cent
il faut partir des territoires et qu'est
ce qu'on constate aujourd'hui sans
rentrer trop dans les débats techniques
mais qu'est ce qu'on constate
aujourd'hui c'est qu'on a des règles qui
sont effectivement très uniforme très
uniforme et qu'on a une grande question
qui nous est posée à vous et nous c'est
notamment cette gestion vous l'avez dit
d'effet adhère c'est à dire grosso modo
du 2e pilier de la pac
ça fait des mois et des mois qu'on parle
de ce sujet donc moi je prends un
engagement s'est très vite de pouvoir
atterrir sur ceux du sur ce dossier de
manière constructive et en échangeant
avec avec vous une opportunité nous sera
donné d'ailleurs puisque l'habilitation
qui permettra au gouvernement de
légiférer par ordonnances sur ce fait
adhère elle est incluse dans le projet
de loi dadu qui sous le contrôle du
ministre du parlement doit venir dans
cette assemblée à la fin du mois de
septembre début du mois d'octobre
ça veut dire que de toutes les manières
il nous faut statuer sur ce sujet d'ici
là parce que c'est à ce moment là où le
législateur que vous êtes devra
trancher sur ce point moi je suis tout à
fait favorable à ce qu'on ait une
territorialisation de plus en plus
massive de ces politiques agricoles sans
aucun doute on connaît les positions des
uns et des autres on connaît aussi les
effets de bord d un des autres vous
prend un dossier que vous connaissez
très bien monsieur le député
l'installation des jeunes agriculteurs
on sait que l'installation des jeunes
agriculteurs est un défi mais massif
moi je voudrais vraiment y passer
beaucoup de temps avec vous parce que
c'est un défi pour nos territoires et on
sait aussi que pour l'installation de
ces jeunes agriculteurs parfois on a des
grandes divergences d'un territoire à
l'autre
donc il faut faire un thé l'ifr partir
de l'intelligence de ces territoires
tout en donnant un certain nombre de
lignes directrices pour s'assurer d'une
certaine convergence dans l'intelligence
territoriale
merci monsieur 2010
[Applaudissements]
vous m'avez pas tout à fait convaincu
mais je compte sur vous et à la veille
des congés
si monsieur le premier ministre n'a pas
encore choisi la destination pourrait
l'emmener parce que je sais que vous
connaissez bien la montagne alsacienne
ainsi que mes chers collègues je vous
convie à un bon repas marcaire avec un
baume acer est un bon verre de
gewurztraminer
merci
l'invitation est notée retenue la parole
est à monsieur jacques marie l'océan
merci monsieur le président mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur jean yves le drian ministre de
l'europe et des affaires étrangères je
vous parle monsieur le ministre non sans
émotion et à plus d'un titre d'abord en
tant que membre des groupes d'amitié
france turquie et france azerbaïdjan
mais aussi en tant que président du
groupe d'amitié france arménie dont de
nombreux membres s'associe à ma question
monsieur le ministre depuis le 12
juillet des affrontements
transfrontalier meurtriers ont lieu
entre l'arménie et l'azerbaïdjan
ces combats interviennent après les
propos du président azerbaïdjanais
il y a aliev qui a menacé de quitter les
pourparlers de paix sur le haut-karabagh
jugeant que son pays avait je cite le
droit de chercher une solution militaire
au conflit
la turquie hélas semble lui apporter son
soutien
nous pouvons que le condamné je rappelle
que la région du haut karabagh qu est
historiquement arménienne ses valets
parsemé d'églises et de monastères
parfois plus que millénaire en témoigne
mais elle fait l'objet de contestations
depuis que en 1921 ce territoire peuplé
à l'époque de 95% d'arméniens fut
rattachée par staline à l'azerbaïdjan
monsieur le ministre
café et que compte faire la france pour
défendre la cause de la paix de la
liberté de la fraternité et de la
démocratie dans la région
éviter que le caucase ne s'enflamme et
trouver une solution politique pacifique
et pérenne dans le conflit du haut
karabagh je vous remercie
merci monsieur le député la parole est à
monsieur jean yves le drian ministre de
l'europe des affaires étrangères
monsieur le
député jacques marie lotion les
événements qui viennent de se passer
autour du 14 juillet dans cette région
sont très préoccupants pour plusieurs
raisons d'abord parce que depuis ce
qu'on a appelé la guerre des quatre
jours en avril 2016 c'est la première
fois qu'il ya des affrontements armés et
aussi avec beaucoup d'emploi puisqu'il
ya eu 19 morts dans ces combats
d'ailleurs un arménien qui a été tué
hier ensuite parce que c'est la première
fois que ces affrontements ont lieu non
pas au haut karabagh mais allez sur la
ligne de contact où il y en avait
régulièrement où se sont déroulés les
conflits de la guerre d'avril 2016 mais
sur la frontière internationale entre
l'arménie et l'azerbaïdjan
et puis la troisième raison qui
complique la situation c'est la crise
sanitaire
ces pays et singulièrement l'arménie
sont particulièrement touchés victimes
de cette crise avec des conséquences
sociales que l'on imagine alors comme
vous le savez monsieur le député
président du groupe d'amitié france
arménie
il y a une mission de médiation qui a
été confiée par l'organisation de la
sécurité et la coopération en europe à
la russie aux états unis d'amérique et à
la france une co présidence à trois dans
une configuration qui peut paraître un
peu bizarre mais que nous exerçons et
nous avons pris des initiatives
nécessaires depuis il ya dix jours pour
aboutir à ce qu'il y ait un cessez le
feu
il est quasiment respectée là en ce
moment et pour qu'il y ait une reprise
des négociations entre les uns et les
autres parce qu'il aura pas de solution
militaire
il faut trouver la solution politique
avec de la bonne volonté de l'engagement
des deux parties je pense qu'on peut
aboutir à cette solution en tout cas
sachez bien que la france comme
coprésident de ceux de ce groupe et de
ce groupe qu'on appelle le groupe de
minsk mettra tous ses efforts pour
aboutir à ce résultat parce que je crois
que nous avons disons-le écoute des uns
et des autres pour aboutir à une
solution pérenne
même si le chemin sera encore long
si monsieur glisse mieux débuter
monsieur le ministre merci pour votre
réponse je vous propose
n'hésitez pas de faire appel aux membres
des groupes d'amitiés parlementaires
que ce soit françois qui france
azerbaïdjan où france-arménie si vous
pensez qu'ils peuvent vous aider
merci je voulais la parole de monsieur
alain david
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre des
affaires étrangères monsieur le ministre
des nouvelles de plus en plus alarmante
nous parviennent de chine sur le sort
réservé aux ouïgours ce en effet on
parle de déportations de masse
d'internement dans des camps de
stérilisation forcée systématique des
femmes de réduction en esclavage de dons
d'organes forcé et de mauvais
traitements généralisée je sais que vous
avez dénoncé les faits que le parlement
européen a voté une résolution demandant
des sanctions ciblées contre les
dirigeants qui participent à ces crimes
contre l'humanité malheureusement pour
l'instant aucune décision concrète n'a
été prise contre l'appareil d'état
chinois les mois international et
réprobation commence à monter il est
important de dissuader les entreprises
européennes de vendre des technologies
de surveillance notamment qui permettent
la répression contre les ouïghours
il est aussi important que les quelques
83 entreprises internationales qui
bénéficient de main d'oeuvre forcée
je répète de main d'oeuvre forcée fasse
rapidement transféré leur usine
ce n'est malheureusement pas suffisant
il convient de sortir d'une certaine
frilosité vis-à-vis de la chine
nous ne sommes pas condamner à
l'impuissance face à pékin
ainsi je pense qu'une commission d'
enquête internationale devrait
rapidement être mise en place afin de se
rendre sur place et de faire toute la
lumière sur la situation des ouigours ce
aussi monsieur le ministre
quelles initiatives notre diplomatie
pourrait-elle rapidement initié en la
matière merci
merci monsieur députés comme suit jean
yves le drian ministre ou de l'europe
des affaires étrangères monsieur le
monsieur le député alain david j'ai eu
l'occasion de m'exprimer sur la
situation au sud chan déjà dans cet
hémicycle la semaine dernière et j'ai
répondu au sénateur vallini sur le même
sujet toujours la semaine dernière je
suis tout à fait convaincu de la
nécessité de prendre la parole dans les
instances démocratiques pour dénoncer ce
qui se passe dans cette région il ya des
pratiques injustifiable qui vont à
l'encontre des principes universels
inscrits dans les grandes conventions
internationales des droits de l'homme
vous avez cité l'internement des
ouigours dans des camps des détentions
massive du travail forcé des
stérilisations forcées la destruction du
patrimoine culturel des des ouigours en
particulier des lieux de culte la
surveillance généralisée de la
population un système répressif globale
dans toute la région et pense que là les
médias aujourd'hui relève tout cela et
c'est tout à fait opportun et nous avons
sur ce sujet pris des positions
extrêmement claires publiques fortes et
compris par ma propre voix la semaine
dernière en particulier en demandant la
fermeture des camps d'internement et
aussi en agissant pour dissuader les
entreprises d'utiliser la main de force
et de get d'assurer leur présence dans
ce territoire il ya une prise de
position européenne d'ailleurs sur ce
sujet mes déclarations de la semaine
dernière ont été suscité des réactions
de la part des autorités chinoises vous
les avez peut-être lu je le redis ici
que j'en ai pris bonne note puisqu'ils
disent que mes propos sont infondées
nous proposons qu'il y ait précisément
une mission internationale est
maintenant d'obsèques d'observateurs
indépendants sous la houlette de la
haute commissaire aux droits de l'homme
madame bachelet qui se rendent sur place
qu'il voit et qui rendent témoignage
puisque si les autorités chinoises
disent que ça n'existe pas alors il faut
aller la tester sur place et je pense ça
serait une bonne étape que vous avez
souligné
et que je reprends volontiers
merci monsieur willy la parole quand
madame aurore bergé
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre de la
culture madame la ministre le jour même
de votre nomination vous vous êtes
rendus à radio france
rappelant par votre présence la force et
l'importance de l'audiovisuel public
l'audiovisuel public nous y sommes ici
parlementaire et singulièrement au sein
de la commission des affaires
culturelles de tous bords d'ailleurs
particulièrement attachée depuis le
début de notre mandat nous avons
travaillé évidemment avec vigilance sur
cette question à la fois sur les enjeux
de la trajectoire budgétaire de
l'audiovisuel public mais aussi pour
rappeler ses missions qui sont des
missions fondamentales et qui plus que
jamais pendant le coc vide et pendant la
période de confinement ont montré leur
importance auprès des français
beaucoup de choses ont été démenties
pendant le confinement on disait que la
télévision n'avait pas d'avenir on dise
avec la tnt n'avait pas d'avenir
on disait que les français se
détourneraient de l'audiovisuel public
et c'est plutôt l'inversé qui s'est
produit
et c'est heureux les parlementaires et
je pense notamment à ceux qui
m'entourent bruno stud heures le
président de la commission florence pro
vandier béatrice piron nous nous sommes
particulièrement mobilisé sur un sujet
qui est l'avenir de france 4 france 4 ce
qui est en jeu c'est non seulement
l'avenir de la création
mais c'est aussi un enjeu d'égalité sur
les territoires parce que nous l'avons
vu là encore pendant la crise tous les
enfants de notre pays n'ont pas
forcément accès au numérique
toutes les familles de notre pays n'ont
pas forcément les facilités d'accès
alors ma question est simple madame la
ministre notre question est simple quel
est l'avenir de france 4 je vous
remercie
merci chers collègues la parole et à
madame roselyne bachelot ministre de la
culture madame la députée en or berger
je voudrais d'abord m'associer aux
compliments aux félicitations que vous
avez adressé aux entreprises de
l'audiovisuel public qui ont rempli
parfaitement leur mission pendant cette
crise pandémique tant au niveau de
l'information de l'éducation des
programmes culturels
ils ont ainsi l zeeuw aider nos
concitoyens à surmonter une crise
pandémique particulièrement violentes et
à mieux en supporter les contraintes
alors vous me posais un certain nombre
de questions sur l'audiovisuel public
il faut d'abord qu'il continue sa
transformation
il subit des mutations considérables il
va falloir qu'ils améliorent les
synergies entre les différentes
entreprises
il va falloir qu'il parachève la
transition numérique c'est absolument
indispensable
vous voulez aussi savoir et c'est tout à
fait normal ce qu'il adviendra du projet
de loi que vous avez beaucoup travaillé
ainsi qu'avec un certain nombre de vos
collègues que vous allez cité il ya
trois paquets d'abord la transposition
des directives sm à tout ce qui concerne
le droit d'auteur bien entendu et la
directive câble et satellite
le sénat l'a adopté nous allons
continuer évidemment dans le cadre de la
loi dadt eu à faire cette transposition
pour ce qui concerne toute une série de
dispositions la lutte contre le piratage
la création d'une autorité de régulation
la modernisation de la tnt là aussi nous
allons l'examiner
[Musique]
disons dans le courant de la cession par
contre nous n'aurons pas le temps du
fait de tout ce qui impose tout ce qui
nous est imposée par la crise pandémique
nous n'aurons pas le temps d'examiner la
création d'une super structure de
l'audiovisuel public
vous m'avez enfin poser la question sur
france ô et sur france 4 et en partie
et sur france 4 avec le premier ministre
nous allons prendre les décisions dans
les prochains jours et vous serez bien
sûr informé dans les meilleurs délais et
nous reviendrons discuter de vente
merci madame la ministre madame bergé
mais aura le dernier mot
merci monsieur le président si le
dernier mot peut-être le menti en france
4 alors je m'en tiendrai à ce mot là en
tout cas les parlementaires et sont
particulièrement attachés je vous
remercie
merci chers collègues je vous rappelle
qu'à la rentrée nous appliquerons de
manière stricte les deux minutes
accordées à ceux qui questionnent et les
deux minutes à ce qu'ils répondent la
séance des questions au gouvernement est
terminé la séance est suspendue